Yes.
Episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is a platform that allows a
dummy like you or me to make their own
professional website.
Squarespace has beautiful designs for
you to start with and all the style
options you need to create a unique
website for you or your business.
It's simple drag and drop interface. It's
just like if you can, you know, send a,
attach some pictures to an email.
Seriously,
you can make a website on Squarespace.
It's super easy to do.
They also offer 24 seven support.
They also have a new logo creator.
We can create a clean and simple logo
design for yourself, for your business,
for anything you're planning on doing.
They have a very simple
and easy ecommerce set up.
Very easy to start selling
shit online with Squarespace.
It's everything that everyone
has always wanted in like the,
the ease of use in creating a website but
literally never existed before. It was,
I hate people that correct you when
you use the term literally, Fuck Ugh,
you they've used,
you know,
they've literally now has that
term is in the dictionary.
Like it's not just figuratively,
like literally if you look up,
the definition of literally has changed
in the actual fucking dictionary.
So when people correct you and say,
actually it's not literally you go,
actually you need to update your fucking
dictionary bitch, because we won.
Okay.
Bad Grammar one Squarespace,
go to squarespace.com get yourself
your own God damn awesome motherfucking
website and a for a free trial
and 10% off your first purchase.
Go to squarespace.com
and enter the code Joe.
That's a free trial and 10%
off your first purchase.
Squarespace is the shit Squarespace. I
didn't even get this space out, right?
Um, seriously. Really good
way to make websites and uh,
you don't need to hire anybody anymore.
That day is over.
Awesome logo I made for you Joe. Boom,
eat dick, yo. And I looking at it like,
how easy did that, how long did that
take you to do? Like one second. Exactly.
That's my new logo. It's a, an
elk and it says eat dick. Yo,
I'm not sure about the bottom part,
but everything else, everything else,
I'm fucking,
I'm on a board.
Son were also brought to you by
[inaudible] Dot Com that's o. N N.
I t if you have never been to on it
before on it is a human optimization
website. We basically sell shit that makes
your body and your brain work better,
whether it's strength and conditioning
equipment like battle ropes and kettle
bells, weight vest, ab wheels, uh,
medicine balls, things along those lines,
things for functional strength or a,
whether it's foods like the new,
more your bar that we
just started selling. Uh,
it's by the same folks
that made the Tonka bar.
And what it is is an ancient
native American recipe for
a Buffalo Jerky bar that
is very healthy. Like it has no
antibiotics, no hormones, gluten
free, no nitrates, no artificial
flavors, no artificial colors.
And you get 14 grams of
protein in every serving,
four grams of fat in every serving. Um,
there's, and there's nothing bad in it.
Like there's, there's no nitrates,
no soy, no MSG, isn't it?
What nitrate where it makes
your Dick hard though.
I think that's nitric oxide son.
You should not be a chemist.
I take a drug record,
Joe Rogan, beautiful.
I think that with my pro gain and my
other stuff that kicked my hair in
anyway on a.com,
use the codeword Rogan and you'll
save 10% off any and all supplements.
The controversial supplements like
I'm shroom tech, sport, new mood.
What these are essentially if you go to
any of those, uh, various, um, uh, items,
any of the various things that we sell,
there's a lot of science behind all of
the stuff. There's a research button,
you click on it, you can find all
the research that's behind. I'm on.
It's supplements,
whether it's Alpha brain,
which we've actually run our
own clinical trial results.
And those are also posted
online. Um, uh, there were,
it was a double blind placebo trial on
the efficacy of Alpha brain and it got
positive results. And we're in
the middle of a second trial now,
which is much larger and
much more extensive. I should
also point out that the,
the trial, the, the positive results were
exactly half of the dose that I take.
It's two pills.
I take four of these bitches crazy because
some love renegade I can't be fucked
with. Is this girth of your chart charro
going to be more a bigger dose? Um,
no it's not. No. The, the two
pill dose is the recommended dose.
It did it help you thinking you
might have seen it helps your memory.
It helps a clinically proven so far.
Uh Huh.
That's the weird thing
about memory though.
I never know where the mine's going
because I've forgotten the things that I
can't remember. That's true.
I think I remember everything,
but obviously I don't know
what I've forgotten. Yeah.
It's whether or not you're
trying to pull it up.
I'll give you some Alpha brand and you
run your own Jim Jefferies clinical trial.
Yeah, man Rogan Doc. Oh. Anyway,
on a.com use the codeword Rogan
save 10% o n n I t codeword Rogan.
If you don't know how to spell my name,
go fuck yourself. Jim Jeffries is here.
While I fuck around and play games.
Just good to the podcast.
Well, good experience. Try by
day Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Nick Diaz.
Yeah. Uh, so that never leaves. That will
stay on. You had a question about Elvis
because these are all mug shots
you've got on your wall here and you,
you've got an Elvis mug shot there.
I wear a tee shirt often
with the Sinatra mugshot.
Ah, I got that one. I have it framed
in my house. Let's just go on.
What was he done for there? It was
um, uh, what is the word tree? No,
it wasn't adultery. It was so what?
Three shagging the guy's wife?
Yes. It was shagging the guy's wife,
but the word that they use seduction.
That's the word
that it says on the actual monk sheet.
That's what I hate. That photo of Sinatra,
that mag shot,
he looks better there than I've ever
looked in any photo in my life where
professionals have taken it and they've
taken a thousand photos and still look
like shit. Well, did you notice how
little he was? Yeah, the mugshot photo,
I think it says 125 pounds.
You won 25 or one 39 the
only a slight fellow,
but also we've been talking about,
obviously we go in, Elvis was at the end,
he was fat. I was fat.
He was like 220 pounds.
I'm like sitting at a cruisy today,
11 at the moment. And you
know what I mean? I go down,
I go down up to about two 15 I
go down to about one 95 and I,
I go through that spectrum my whole life.
Right.
But Elvis was by today's standards,
just eh, it was all right.
Yeah. See, that's what I look like now.
That's at the very end.
He was anywhere between two 20 and
two 30 but what was the two 30 well,
he was probably shorter than me.
I'm six foot one,
so I get a little bit of leeway.
He's probably, what, five 10 Elvis?
How tall was five was Elvis.
God Damn, he got fat. Does that.
But he was dead like a year later.
Yeah, he was on his way out. He died.
And my sister's birthday.
I'll never forget. Really.
He died the year I was born.
I always liked the fact that I was
alive and John Lennon and Elvis Presley,
we were alive. Apparently the picture
was taken just for fun, all the,
all the magnets. So he never
went to prison for any of them.
Elvis was a law enforcement nut and
the picture was taken just for fun.
That's according to one site on the
Internet because that could have been when
he went to visit the FBI and we've
visited Nixon and all that type of stuff
because he was there. He was there. He
visited Nixon for the war against drugs.
Yeah. It's hilarious. That bends
the beetle. Bailey's Beatles, eh,
they're all doing drugs and we've got
to stop that. We're going to start it.
We're going to stop on my own.
He was apparently arrested, uh,
in the 1950s for speeding. Yeah,
but that was before he made it.
Well,
when did he make it?
Uh, 1954, I think four would
have been around that era.
Sun Records.
Well, that would be him then. That
was be like right as he made it.
He was speeding. Yeah. But he's not
like early twenties taken hockey,
10 year old speeding in the car.
We all got those.
I remember the first time
I got caught speeding,
I was 16 and I just didn't have the money.
So I thought if I broke down in tears,
the copper,
no, of course just fucking
funny. And the worst thing is
my brother is a cop and uh,
he reported it to my brother and then
my brother tease me in the near future.
Well probably they used to do awful
things as, as a couple of my brother,
my brother's named Danny Nugen
on, I think that's a bad, this,
he's a member of the rod squad
now. And uh, I got, I got,
I was driving home and it's sa at 17,
which is still not the legal
age to drink in Australia.
And I'm driving home and I had two beers
now it would have been under the limit,
but still, I'm not even allowed to have
two BZ me because I'm 17. Right, right.
I get pulled up, I get breathalyzed the
guard guys, please bring in the tube.
And I said, my brother was a
sergeant at that stage and I was like
go, you know, uh, Denny Nugent,
you know, done. He Nugent,
you know is right and let you guys
know I never heard of him. Right.
So you guys off to his vehicle
is there for like 15 minutes.
I'm just sitting in the
car, just panicking now he
comes back out and he goes,
step out of the vehicle.
I was, you're a problem.
Anything over just step out of the
vehicle right now as I step out,
he cuffs me and smacks me onto
the bonnet of the car. Right?
And I thought, oh Jesus Christ,
oh fuck, fuck, fuck. Like this.
Right.
And then I'll get my brother laugh
finger on the radio. Like he's actually
gone back to his car, radio the station,
talk to my brother and he said,
it's going to be shit out of him.
You know what I mean?
Am because it's cops and they're going,
I was just joking with you.
I'm wiping tears away from ours. Look
good job guys. Well done. Thanks for that.
I bet.
You know,
I still have one more line of defense
and it's mum went and told mom on him and
when I go,
what does your mom do?
Well,
my mom was still angry because I shouldn't
have been drinking to begin with and
Blah, blah blah. But I still
got in trouble for that.
But yeah, it's, it's, uh,
now he's like, he's in the swat team, so
he's like the guy who, you know, if I can,
where's the helmets and swings in,
in the machine gun on top of Jesus Christ.
And the thing is, for the longest
time my parents were so like, oh,
your brother's a cop was like,
like the most upstanding job
you could have in our family.
And so my brother became a weapons
training before he's in a sweat. Same.
So he would learn different holds
and restraints and stuff like that.
There was many a Christmas where
I was staying there. And then,
then my brother goes a, we've, uh, we've
been traveling over to America with,
learned some new holds from
the American cops. And, uh,
we look one where we can
basically restrain the person
until the whole shoulder
goes numb and they kind of like,
well, some guys do it on Jim. No, no,
I don't want you to fucking do it.
Why are you doing this to me? Right.
Then he comes up and grabs like,
I just don't touch me.
You guys see how he's resisting them?
See how he's resisting.
Always end with me with my
fucking head and the Chevy.
He shagged Paul just got crying
again. [inaudible] mom, man,
your mom sold you down the river.
I would think that moms,
the last thing they would see want to
see is one son torturing the other side.
And uh, she, because my father wasn't
much of a physical disciplinarian,
my mother was very keen on
using my oldest brother as,
as the muscle when we got too big.
Ah,
how old is your oldest brother is
probably seven years older than me. Oh,
that's a big gap. And then I have another
brother, he's five years older than me.
Oh Jeez.
And I was meant to be a girl because
my mum desperately wanted to have it.
I have a baby girl so
she gave it one more go.
And then when I didn't
come out of baby girl,
she didn't unwrap the blanket for the
first four days. After the first month,
she never unwrap up the blanket cause
she didn't want to see my genitalia and
she didn't hold me for
the first four days. Whoa.
She went into science depressant over
having another boy and then she got really
passionate about
collecting porcelain dolls.
So there was four main living
in a house and his house,
it was just filled with
fucking creepy dolls.
I remember in the old days when you could
put something on top of your TV that
was sort of a joy.
Like you go go karting,
you'd beat your brother and
you had the first trophy.
So for a week he'd put that on top of the
TV because you know he'd constantly be
looking at it. When niggle is shit
out of me, those days are gone. Right.
But my mother would always have like a
different porcelain doll. Maybe like a,
I could porcelain clown juggling one of
those little statuettes Oh, something.
Something very upsetting.
We'd always be looking at you whilst you
were trying to enjoy a Betamax version
of star wars. When did you find out about
the not being held? She, she told me,
she tells me all the time that she always
wanted to have a go so she didn't even
have a boy's name ready to go.
Like she was just,
and you didn't want to
have the ultrasound.
She didn't want to know it wasn't going
to have fuck is wrong with people when
it comes to wanting the gender so badly
that they get upset and the thing is my
mom, it's not like she's a super feminine
woman where she would have been like,
it might be like I'm
not a good looking guy,
but my parents wouldn't have made
her know, renders looking woman.
Like it would have been just a chinless
pile thing just just with thin wispy
hair. It wouldn't have been
a good look and go, boy,
boy is the best thing they could
have hoped for with the fucking piss.
That's been pissed into my Jean Paul
already from the different sites.
I've got a great story about, but
women don't see that. I've got a, yeah,
of course they then if you're a
woman and you're surrounded by men,
I think it might be my mother. My mother
is 300 pounds and she thought she,
I don't know if whether the
intention was to make a hot chick.
I don't know if that was what she does.
She does want it to Mike ago.
But I got a story that I don't want to
tell because in front of my girlfriend
because it will upset her because I would
make my life a bit harder and I don't
want to tell it on, on any tonight shows
or anything. So I'll tell her here.
But I just did a Zombie
movie in Australia,
which isn't anything to do with story,
but they're always in Australia. And so,
I mean it's dry and my parents
drive to Canberra where we are,
where we're at on the weekend to
spend a day with me. It's fair enough.
I see my parents and in
six months or something,
so I'm spending time with my mom and dad.
Now back in the early nineties my father
was getting closer to retirement and
then he found a credit card bill because
my mother took care of the money fan
out that she'd run up
$90,000 worth of bills,
which made my dad had to work an extra
sort of eight years past retirement.
The Pi, these all often, she'd
kept it all secret. All right,
so now my parents have got to retirement,
they own the house and they just get a
pension of like Australian government
gives each person like
$300 a week pension,
which is like two 60 American.
Right.
So my parents live off that and then,
but my father takes care of all the money.
He pays all the bills and he balanced
the books because my mom can't be trusted
when it comes to shopping. And so I'm
talking to my parents. My mom goes,
all I want is my half of the money,
his half of the money and then will,
he can have his half of the money.
It will split the bills and then I
can do what I want with my money,
but instead I'm given an allowance
because I'm not responsible with money.
I said, ma'am, you can't
take care of the money ma'am.
You can't because you'll fuck
it up. You'll go online, you've,
you've found Internet shopping now
you'll fuck it up. You'll get rid of,
you'll lose everything and
get more credit. Cards will
be terrible. And she goes,
Oh,
I'm not the problem with money anymore.
Your father's the one that spends all
the money. Now we're in a public bar,
by the way, there's many people sitting
around us. It's a very public, open area.
Your father's the one who spends all
the money now and then she pointed,
my dad goes, tell him, tell him
what you spend your money on.
And I've already clicked what this might
be. And I've gone, oh no, wait, look on.
I want to know. I don't want
to know. And then it goes,
your father gets prostitutes,
right? And I've gone,
Oh God,
just shut up both of your
employees and she's gone.
Yet every Wednesday,
your father,
before he goes to play lawn bowls goes
off and gets himself a prostitute and
then my dad went,
not every Wednesday,
he didn't even try.
Not every Wednesday makes you,
it sounds like at least
three out of four Wednesdays.
It takes a week off every now
and again. Yeah, like it costs,
you mean Australian money
for a very cheap prostitute.
It's legal in Australia and a brothel,
maybe a hundred bucks for a pretty low
in sort of girl or Robin Tag Palace.
So he went to a place to get
it done. He didn't, no, no, no.
It's not like here where you've got to
go to a hotel and all type of stuff.
They just brothels and they're,
they're very legal and very well
signposted and stuff. It's not,
it's not such a big deal in Australia.
It's actually makes it a bit safer,
if anything,
because the girls have to get tested,
they have to bring their results in
all the time and they're paying taxes.
It's safer.
It's like everything else.
As soon as the government
says it can't be a legal,
when it's something that
people really enjoy doing,
lowest divorce substantially.
Of course it does.
I don't begrudge my dad for doing this.
I just don't want to hear about it.
They're in their seventies. My mom
morbidly obese. My Dad still quite fit.
Of course he wants to get
his end away sometimes
is end away. There's a book called
the sex at dawn by this guy,
Dr Chris Ryan. I do a podcast
with him once a month and uh,
he basically goes over in great detail.
Like what,
what is the root cause of, of, you know,
the reason why men want to breed
with more than one woman. Why is um,
why is marriage do so poorly? Why does so
many people want to stray? It's genetic.
It's 100% genetic.
If you could squash that with
robot fucked dolls or prostitution,
that's legal, like whatever you
have that's non relationship based,
he's going somewhere ruining
anyone else's life. Right?
You're just getting some sex.
That's it. Only sex. What did,
what are prostitutes over in,
in Australia?
Are they thought of differently
than prostitutes here?
Like is it not that big of it?
It's not as big of a deal.
They, I thought of the,
they're not like given a load of
respect or anything. It's not like,
like in Germany, Holland and stuff is
really not a big deal, you know. But,
uh, no, it's, it's still
kept fairly, you know,
th th th the clubs that cold things
like the big one in Melbourne called the
daily planet and it looks like it looks
like the front of the daily planet from
Superman with the big globe.
You know,
Melbourne that's in Melbourne.
That's the brothel I went to when I took
my friend with muscular dystrophy to
the brothel work,
which is what my TV show legit,
which is on Wednesdays and Fx exit
10:00 PM we need writings. Um, but it,
it, it, uh,
that was the whole basis of my TV show
was taken a disabled guy to a brothel.
Yeah. Wow. This season,
incidentally, talking about my dad,
my father will be played
by George Lazenby who, uh,
was James Bond for one movie. George
Lazenby. Why do I know that name?
He was James Bond. No,
that's not why I know it.
It's actually there's a Paul
lays and beat who's um, uh,
mixed martial arts commentator
far right. All George. Oh,
George isn't related to anything of that
lays and B is what got me. I was like,
why do I know that George is just,
George did one,
James Bond film was booked to do seven
and then he told him to fuck off after
after Sean Connery because
you went ah, this, this,
this franchise isn't going to go on for
too long because it was 1970. He's like,
everyone wants to look
like long hair and beards.
No one wants to look like this fucking
idiot from a bank and he told him to fuck
off and he never was
really in a movie again.
You can't tell him to fuck off
when they ask you to be James Bond.
He was in my own model, never
acted before. Really. He just,
he just went straight into
it. He's like, he's got some
fucking stories, man. No, no.
If you, if you pull up a
picture of the guy, if you a,
if you've taught George Lazenby,
you'll see like now he's in his mid
seventies but like in these day was the
number one male model on earth in like
1969 the number one male model on earth
and he was from a country
town in Australia there is
Hansel bastard,
beautiful genetics.
It's got that 1970 handsome
thing going on too.
That's like that wouldn't
really fly today. Yeah.
It's like they had poor nutrition.
They're eating fucking
well. Everyone was sort of shorter. He's
like six foot four and he's sort of a,
you know,
we got to like you guys a,
a bit of a bubble head motion going
on in a big dimple in his chin.
Yeah, but like look at his face it,
there's almost something about his face.
Like pull that picture up again.
Oh,
it's like the good looks in
the 80s with different people.
Like Molly Ringwald wouldn't ruin.
Now pull the same picture up.
Go back to that picture.
There's a,
like there's something about this guy and
I don't know if it's his style of hair,
but that's not a guy from today,
but you know what I mean?
Like in 2014 okay, what, who
is, how old is he? About 37
38 years old. And his photo,
no, no, no, no, no. This is, no,
no. If he's 70 now this is 19 set.
That's 1969 when that film was made,
so he was probably 24 or something
like that. How's that possible?
Back in the day everyone was
smoking and drinking and it was a,
you all looked a little bit more leathery.
Put that picture back up,
look, look, look at it. Like
if you saw that photo and
said, where's this guy from?
Like what time is this?
You would say like the 70s what is that?
This is like something
about his fucking face.
Like that's not a guy that was born after,
you know, 1920 or something like that.
You know what I mean? Does that
weird thing that they have like a,
he looks like a guy from this,
like Burt Reynolds in his prime.
That guy doesn't exist
today. No, we're all,
we're all slightly changing
something in the field.
I think that women's faces in the ids
where rounder. Oh I think you're right.
Moon faces.
Oh that was deemed to be a good look
and we now shun the moon faced woman.
The moon face woman in the 80s was
a thing. Yeah. Is it a weight thing?
It's a weight thing, right? I don't know.
Like you guys know. I'm like that's a,
that's a real issue for women to get so
skinny that they lose like the roundness
of their face. Like they want
to have like, like sculpted
cheeks. It's a moon face.
Two. That's a quarter moon.
What do you,
what is he going to do now that he's
retired too and a lot of comedy.
Apparently I'm not doing a lot of shows
at the comedy magic club cause he's to
do every Sunday night.
He used to try it as monologue.
I'm there actually the
30th I was just there.
I'm doing probably like
one or so every month.
I probably do at the Sunday nights
cause he's, he's on the road now.
He's just doing comedy. Is He
a good standup? I shooed me,
let me tell you something. At one point
in time he was thought of and it's, it's,
it's tough to judge because you got to
judge it based on the fact that this 1970
and everything from 1970 doesn't hold
up like a few movies set for him.
There's a few movies but like
television shows for example,
try to watch a television show from
the 70s they're very, very dated.
So his comedy, it's hard to
date it just like Lenny Bruce.
I always can see that he's the
most important standup ever,
but I don't want to watch them. I don't
want to listen to them. I've tried,
I sit down and listen to the tapes
and I try to s two, two alien a time.
It's not us. You know, we were too free.
You know what he's saying? It's done.
You can get like from the ids,
you can still enjoy pickle pry.
You can still watch,
Ken isn't,
you can still watch things changed
considerably though. I think in the,
from the 1960 [inaudible] 1970s Cosby.
Yeah.
Yeah. You can still, yeah,
well he's a master. You know,
he's a really a master wordsmith and a
master storyteller, but it's also, he's,
he was dealing mercy that
I at that stage at, Oh,
I've got a wife and young
kids and it's just how it is.
And that stuff always sticks
around if you're a political guide,
always dates very horrible.
Yes. That's so true.
Or if you're talking about society and
how this is fucked up and that it's
fucked up, that doesn't, you know, it's,
it's interesting culturally to go back
and listen to some shit where people were
complaining about,
you know,
like Lenny Bruce has some stuff where
he's complaining about politicians.
It doesn't, it doesn't make you
laugh though. But anyway, Leno,
it's hard to say. Well, when
you look at his stuff now,
because it just seems so pedestrian.
But I think that back in the 1970s
Lenna Lenna was a motherfucker.
The reason I say it's because all
the comics said they all, yeah,
they're all the guys who knew
him back then go. He was a
bad motherfucker. He was,
he was the legit comic.
He was really good.
He was the guy in the club
that everyone in when he's,
he came down who's a hard worker but
then somewhere along the line he stopped
writing. This is kinda
interesting. Like he would go to a,
he would do shows like an and
do the same show the next year,
go back to the same
place next year verbatim.
Every joke from the beginning to the
end and like the people in Edmonton,
I was in Edmonton and they were
telling me like we went to see him be,
he did another set and
like play some of this.
I'm originally from the United States
and United States. People hit tonight.
It's funny cause he's in America.
I have a slight cold,
I have to apologize for that.
I've had is about two weeks went to
the hospital over here when the large
hospitals in California, I don't want to
say the name, healthcare isn't this day.
This is absolutely true.
I went in and charge me $40 gave me some
pills to take and on the way out as a
doc, my throat is still really solid. Do
you think I should have? My tonsils out
is a specialist and I'm showing the best
hospitals in California. Says to me,
well what are you
watching the local news
shut the fuck up.
Everybody who told me he's great,
you shut the fuck up. I imagine,
imagine if they buy came into you
and before the podcast I say, I said,
I want your opinion
and you ran that bar
and then the guy goes,
what do you think?
Yeah,
and then there were Steve Martin,
but that's the beginning of a bit.
That's what the beginning of a rant
like what do I think, motherfucker?
Isn't this your job that you've got
to go into the next week? Then we'll,
it would be a bit, that would be the bid.
It wouldn't be, it was a setup for a bit.
Steve Martin was still funny. Yeah,
he was brilliant and that was,
this is from the same year and I
bet you it blows all that away.
Well he was very different.
You know Steve Martin was one of the
most uniquely original like onstage
performance.
I can't believe he brought out to so
many recordings and not actual video.
Like you're such a visual act to go,
oh I'm going to have an arrow on my
head and put this onto a cassette.
One of my,
what I was going to say about Jay Leno
was Jay Leno stopped putting things out.
He doesn't do anything. It doesn't do an
HBO special, won't do a showtime special.
It doesn't do anything. Have you
noticed like there's no body of work.
There's like one thing
he did for showtime,
like in the early 1980s and I
used to have it on a VHS cassette,
but after that, nothing. And you know
when they ask them, but I was like, wait,
why would I do then I get there
at showtime, I gave him my bit.
My whole act is going to write
a new act. No, give it to them.
And now this is how it's gonna make
me millions of dollars because his
attitude, like his act was like a,
he's just real old school in that respect.
Like those guys,
they thought about if they did an
HBO special, they didn't think, oh,
this is just going to get my comedy
out to more people. They'll enjoy it.
It'll get more people to come
see me. No. It was like, oh,
I'm going to give them my Emma selling
my aunt and then I can't do my Eric.
Then if I can't do my act, I'm losing
all that. I eat that. I get to my yet.
I tried to do a Davy Day every sort
of 18 months or so and then yeah,
I retire the material as
soon as I've done it. Yeah,
we all do that now, I think. I
think that's the new era. I mean,
once the Internet came along,
I think that's mandatory.
You know George Carlin always did it
and then Louie CK started doing it and
telling people that he did it and then
you start looking around who all the
people that do it. Like bird does it,
you do it. Um, you know, Ari does it.
It's, it's one of those things now
I think the kind of everybody does.
It's expected.
Yeah.
Yeah. I think I also, now I don't do,
I won't do stand up on television for
four minutes. I want either. Good for you.
That's for fucking year.
I just knocked back doing Fallon
for that and they're like,
like not anything special.
Like if I can be a guest on a show,
like I'm doing Kimble next
week or whatever, that's fine,
but I don't want to burn four minutes
that I could put onto an actual special,
well, not only that, it's not your act.
Yeah. And it doesn't, I don't translate
well over four minutes. No one knows.
I feel like the tonight
show culture in America,
the late night show culture in America
fucked up a lot of comedians for a very
long time because they'd come over to
Europe and they look at all the British
acts and go,
Geez,
you all your stories are so long winded
and autonomous stuff where everyone over
here seemed to for a very long time
trying to make a snappy five minutes.
And that's not where it's
at in the long term. Yes,
totally. Right. It ruined Boston
comedy. There's a whole special,
a whole documentary that kind of France,
Alameda,
who was a Boston comic did about
it called when standup stood out.
And it's all about Steven, right?
Making it and Steven. Right. Getting on.
Was it Letterman? Did Steven Right?
Get on Letterman or tonight show? Uh,
it was Letterman.
Probably w whichever one it was either
the Letterman or tonight show the, the,
the, the documentary is excellent,
but it shows how everybody change.
Then they all started
doing clean material there.
I'll start trying to get
on television until like,
when am I going to get fucking
picked up? What's going on? Well,
when's this going to happen to
me? This is a, the documentary.
There was nothing.
It was like being on an island in the
only thing there was was trying and make
the audience laugh.
This city by storm and without even
knowing it ignited the biggest standup
revolution.
Me In here. Hi Girl, how are Ya?
I love that
that was unnecessary
hold apart by excess success,
clashing egos,
even death threats.
All in the name of stand up comedy.
Comedy has become a thriving business.
It's club owners spilled their rooms
to capacity weekend after weekend.
It was a really good
time to be doing stamina.
That was like the beginning of thinking.
There's a big future in this critics
called when standup stood out.
Hugely entertaining and hilarious and
have voted it one of the greatest standup
movies of all time. Convenience for
Jews like rock stuff. It's like,
what do we call unbroken
official selection at the Montreal comedy
festival and winner of the Telluride
independent film festival
built type friends. So Lomita.
It's a great movie,
but the point being they're yummy. Look
Amazing, Huh? That was when he was,
when he, he was pretty revolutionary
man. Hey, Steven Wright came along,
nobody was like him before
he came to see me at Caroline's and a
with these promises or something like
that. And um, you know,
after you signed your DVDs and siding and
doing photos and stuff from that foyer
and he waited in line with everyone and
he came and bought a DVD and side goes,
I thought you were great like that. Right.
And I was like, what? Who is this kid?
I know this kind of thing,
but he's just like,
he's just like an old guy in a baseball
bat. And I went, oh, Steven, right.
Anyway, yeah, yeah, yeah. And then
he walked away and then I went
standing next to all these comedy
fans and no one had noticed him.
It's the beard,
right?
Soso also the hat,
but you wouldn't expect him to queue up
if you went to the front of the line and
said hello.
People would have noticed him because
he stood there so incognito and did it.
And then I went, fucking hell,
everyone. That was Steven ride.
And then all the people who were waiting
to take a photo of me chased off,
no one that took a photo with
me after that or bought DVDs.
I was in the middle of
having a conversation with
Robin Williams at the Improv
and I didn't realize it was Robin Williams
until halfway into the conversation.
I thought he was just some dude who came
to the show and wanted to talk to me
after the show and he's talking to me
about the dolphin bit, the dolphins,
the Eden Mushrooms,
and or eaten a pot Brownie.
I went on a boat and I had this life
changing experience in Hawaii playing with
dolphins and I'm telling the story on
stage and Robin Williams comes up to me
and he's, he's talking to me about the
bid and we're talking and I'm like, oh,
it's just this cool old dude.
This is fucking Robin Williams and shit.
He's a tiny little fella,
but it was just,
it was a bizarre thing like in the middle
of the conversation. I'm just going,
I'll, thanks man. Thank you. Whoa.
I have a theory on why actors in some
comedians are super short in comparison to
the general populace need for attention.
Yeah.
I was at the Fox with the TV show.
There's a potty they have for Fox
for everything that's Fox related,
where star of every show
has to show up. It's in your
contract, you have to be there. Right.
And all the reporters go
around and talk to your site.
So there's people like this famous people
and then there's like Jennifer Lopez
walked in and then all the
famous people were like, wow,
this isn't a real famous person. You
know. But then I was staying next to like,
like uh, Keith Sutherland was like, looked
like he was five foot nothing to me.
Really? Yeah he was, he's a big
guy cause he plays Jack Bauer.
You think he's a big guy.
And then Martin Freeman was there cause
he's in now the new Fargo and he's a
itty bitty
Fargo.
They have a Fargo TV show now.
Yeah. Effects to bring
it out. And it's got,
it's got Billy Bob Thornton and
Martin frame and Kate Walsh is in it.
Yeah.
Holy Shit. Who is, does it have
anything to do with the Cohen brothers?
Uh, it's, it, I don't know if it's to,
but it's being reviewed through the roof.
People are saying it's the best thing.
It's coming out in like 16 days.
Oh, that's beautiful. Oh, that's,
I fucking love that movie.
That's one of my all time favorite
comedies because there's no jokes in the
entire fucking thing. It's just fuck
up after fuck up after, you know,
just, it's a completely character
driven thing. That car salesman,
the failure car salesman that fucks
everything up. What's that cat's name? Uh,
I don't know. I haven't seen
the guy who was in shameless
show them the billboard that posts,
they got the bus stops,
which is like a knitted fucking rug.
Ah, that's pretty cool. What is
that guys? What's that guy's name?
Who uh, it's on that shameless
show on HBO or on Showtime? Uh,
the guy who plays the lead. Yeah,
he's in mystery man as well. Yeah.
Was that just the shovel bill Macy? Yeah.
Right. William H Macy. What do you match?
My is, he's a very nice guy. I met
that guy when I was on news radio.
He's super friendly, very, very friendly
guy. Is He short though? Uh, I'm short.
So it's hard to tell.
Everybody seems giant to me.
Everything is,
everything in this world is just like
simply used to a bit is everything is just
people trying to pick up chicks cause
that's why you get into anything like not
not in the long term, but in your
younger years, in your teens.
It's just about how can I make women
how Scott, how can I make money?
So if you're at school and
you're a good looking guy,
then that's your why you're meeting women.
If you're just a really good looking
guy and if you're really good at sport,
that's your why. But if you're
short, you better be fucking funny.
Or if you're not good looking,
you better be funny.
Or if you're not funny and
you're all those things,
then you better learn how to
do a Shakespearian monologue
in fucking drama class.
I better have something you
better have some little,
makes you a little thing that's
different from everybody else.
So I think that's why all the actors,
I think re cause all the actresses a toll.
Some of them are,
there's a lot of shorter,
they're like Nicole came in,
she'd say she marries Tom Cruise,
he's itty bitty feller.
He's not as Itty bitty is. Everybody
says it's Sorta like the polling thing.
Her new husband's really small. Well, you
know, Napoleon wasn't really a short guy.
I didn't know that.
British propaganda.
Oh William was actually taller than the
average person at the time. Really? Yeah.
Yeah.
Well it wasn't tall compared to today.
He's like five six. Yeah. But
back then everybody was fucking,
they were really tiny. Right. So that
was thinking he's four. But Tom Cruise,
apparently I've, I've talked to people
like I've met Sylvester Stallone.
He's not that small. Everybody would say.
So most of the loans, only five, six,
he played a rocky and the movies, he
was a heavier, he's not five, six.
I met the guy, he's at
least five, 10 maybe taller,
and he was wearing some shit in his
shoes. I don't know. But I'm five,
eight I don't wear any shit in my shoes.
And I where I'm standing like right
next to the guy and he's taller than me.
I met Ben Kingsley and
he's like the opposite.
They try to make him look smaller in
film it was a reasonable size guy.
But whenever you seem in film they try
to make him look like a little tiny
menacing book.
Well when Bar Brad Pitt and Tom Cruise
did that vampire movie together,
Tom Cruise walked on like
a platform around him.
So they were like similar heights.
So like everywhere they walked
when they were, you know,
doing the thing like Brad
Pitt is essentially walking
into a ditch that may or
may not be true. I wasn't
there when it was filming. No,
I might have just made that up.
It might be,
might be just total Richard
Gere dribble in the ass.
Even on my TV show I fed it. We'd
win the season. I get the kids,
two girls and one girl was like five
foot tall and Mongo was six foot tall.
It definitely looks better when you're
kissing a six foot tall. Go. Really? Yeah,
because like I'm the same height as that.
You just have to turn
your head and you like,
but when all of a sudden he kiss in a
real short person and you're hunched over,
right, it doesn't look cool on film. Yeah.
That's why they like you to pick them up.
Uh,
say I'm on a toll weak person.
I can't do that. We all have our
limitations. Is this the actors? Okay,
so Danny Devito suit easy is super
small. Yeah, he's five foot and then uh,
I think he's under J. Fox is
just a five foot four. Uh,
same with Emilia estimators.
Then you go up to the woody Allen's
and they tested Emilio. Estefan is,
is five foot four I, Yup. See? How do I
know they're not making this up though?
Woody Allen's taller and Emilio Estevez
for real. Woody Allen's five, five.
Yeah. He's a funny little
fella. And Jack Black.
I passed him yesterday at the
airport and no one was bothering him.
And You wonder why.
I think he was wearing his neck pillow.
It was covering up a lot of these fights.
He had it like with the little
velcro strap around his neck.
He just looked like a schlumpy sorta guy
who had to get his flight and he didn't
look like a movie style.
I'll tell you that much.
That's a good move in the
neck pillow because no one,
if you don't want people talking to
wear a neck pillow because there's that
extra step that they have to take,
like cause that fucking guy wearing a
neck pillow and then they decided not to
talk.
It's not sure that it looks like you're
obviously ready for a slate so you don't
want to be bothered. Bothered
bothers someone who wants to sleep.
It's a very good point.
People the same type of people that
bother you while you're eating. Yeah.
Do you get people that come up to you
while you do that? After he got a high,
I don't want to, I don't want to interrupt
you, but I interrupt you. Will you do?
You do want to interrupt me. You feel
bad about it? I want to interrupt you,
but I feel bad about it
is what you should say.
Yeah.
They're just trying to find a way to be
not rude while they're being rude or not
even being rude. I understand
that people want to say hello,
especially if you're just saying the show.
If you're eating and you
have a mouthful of food. Yes.
That's where I draw the line.
Like when you're sitting down to eat
and you're with your friends and people
come over to the table, like if everybody
did that, it would be fucking chaos.
Like there's a certain amount of,
you know,
of privacy that a person should or just
the piece that a person should be able
to get and while I'm person's eating
their meal, that's where I draw the line.
Well, how, how are you happy with your
level? You almost famous to me, right?
I'm mildly famous. You're famous,
famous, and then there's the next.
You don't want to go there.
You don't want to go, I think.
I think I'd like to go up to
about where you are and then stop
low. Even back it down a little.
I'm trying to back it down a little.
I'm trying to take, take a little
bit of the edge off. It's like,
so at the moment I get stopped,
I would say four times a day in three
of those people are just say, Hey Jim.
And then that's great and that's great.
And then there'll be one personal
take photos and that's no problem.
And that's where I'm at right now.
But I'm not at the stage where I
can ring a restaurant up and go,
Jim Jefferies needs a table and they'll
fucking find a table because most of the
population doesn't know who I am.
So I'm not,
I would like that because I liked it.
I'm lazy with my reservations.
That's what I would like to
get to table restaurant tables.
Yeah, restaurant tables helps if you
were a club hopper and you want it to,
ah, I got a young kid, um, you
know, I might club up again,
it may be later on in life,
but I can't at the moment.
There's no club at the moment. I'm
just fucking daycare guy. Like,
like I'll tell you my sign on
Trump's rallies white again.
So I started going back to the James.
So I got a gym and there's a daycare at
my gym where I can take my son and just
drop him off.
And there's like two ladies in their
50s that just sort of work behind the
counter.
And one of my son who's 16 months old
just fucking loves one of these ladies is
this old Asian lady and he lights up
when he sees her and she loves him.
She'll be playing with other
kids and when she sees my son,
she'll just drop what she's
doing and just go, hey bank.
And then she says the same
thing every time she'll go,
there's my boyfriend here
he is possibly my boyfriend.
My boyfriend gives me kisses. And then
she starts kissing him all over the face,
right? And then guys enjoy
your workout. And I walk off.
Now I can't do that with a baby girl.
I can never go.
There's my girlfriend, my girlfriend
gives me kisses. Give it here.
Enjoy your workout. Why is that? Why
is that so I don't want to do that.
Mind you. I'm not, I'm not fighting for
the freedom to do this in the near future.
I just think it's a very odd,
I have a whole bit about it. Yeah. The,
there's no sexual equality and
child molesting because there's a,
there's a commercial,
I don't know if you've ever seen the
commercial where there's just for men.
Baby was a bit just from Madison Shit.
That old dudes putting their beard,
beard's gone.
Gray is a baby with a beer
and he's driving a Porsche
with a grown woman next to
him and the baby goes to
the club and he's dancing.
All these women are running
around kissing him and my,
what I'm saying is in that bed is there's
no sexual equality and John Lawson,
you couldn't make that same
commercial with the sex is reversed.
Look at this baby.
She's got a grown woman.
The baby gets out of the car
and I look at the bouncer,
he recognizes that many points a finger
at him like, oh, it's you. You fuck.
And the guy goes in there and he's
got a bottle. Look, he's got a bottle.
Just in case you're thinking, well,
maybe it's a little eccentric midget.
So he's doing his little dance and look
surrounded by pussy and a couple of gay
dudes. We just wish they
could get them to turn over.
This baby is the shit.
And if you switch the sexist,
if you had a bunch of dudes with
Tarzan, loin cloths, swinging cock,
like that's baby face, height to
vagina, that babies dancing around.
Well, I know China's or write an
ad that's making fun of something.
It's a comedy of commercial. It's meant
to be a joke. But even in real life,
I dunno about you.
But whenever you hear like there's a guy
who's been molesting the fucking school,
the, the, the, the, the volleyball team,
you always go that fucking creep, right?
But then as soon as you hear there's a
female teacher that had sex with a 13
year old boy, you always got, all right,
I'll have to see the photo of this woman.
And then if the woman's caught a hot,
you're like, Nah, I could see where he,
you know, I don't even blame the kid. I'm
like, no, I would never blame the kid,
but I'm like, eh. On and
off. He had a bad time. Yeah.
Is that wrong? No, it's not wrong
at all. What I say to my school,
who I would've loved to have fucked when
I was 13 I used to masturbate it to her
all the time.
There's nothing wrong with it. If she's
hot, that's what people need to accept.
There is something wrong with demand.
The difference is a man can
molest a 13 year old girl.
A woman can't molest a 13 year old boy.
She could just let him fucker. Yeah.
They're two different things.
Yeah.
And I say that women develop faster.
They do. They do in a lot
of ways. They just, um,
they're not allowed to fuck his early.
They can enjoy it. They can enjoy it.
At 13, there's something really creepy
about a man fucking, the 13 year old.
But if you found out your son got caught,
you know,
with the teacher bent over
the desk and he's banging her,
you fucking be really
kind of proud of him.
Yeah. It wouldn't be. It'd be
like, Oh, you shouldn't do that.
But it's, it's, it's funny,
like Paul Walker when he died, he, Eh,
they found out that he had a girlfriend
for like eight years or something and
when he started dieting,
uh,
she was 16 and he was
34 and then on the TV.
But then it's like that weird
thing that when their celebrity,
even at the end of time at tonight,
we're like,
but she was very mature earn she
uh, and you're like, no, no, no, no,
no statutory.
Right man.
You can't just change the rules
because the guy is dead now.
First of all,
no.
But how good must have that pussy been
34 year old movie star is freaking out
about a 16 year old.
Not that good. If you can pull a picture
of shit might not be a good thing.
I mean, yeah, she might've had a, she
might've been dynamite [inaudible] pussy,
those ones as well. Those girls
with other girls are like this.
She is the 24 or something before she,
but I don't,
I don't begrudge him fucking 16 year old
girl in the sense that you can see some
16 year old goes where you're going and
it's legal in the UK and Australia are,
it's not like it's,
I understand wanting to have sex
with a fully developed 16 year old.
What I don't get is him dating her.
Pull up that picture again. Does that
is an odd picture man. She's like,
oh well she's in her 20s
yeah,
this is like when she's like they'd been
dating for seven years or something.
You know, I hate the idea of,
look, I have daughters first.
The first thing I'm going to say, this
is not something I'm really entertaining,
but I hate the idea that if two people
really do love each other and for
whatever reason they're perfect together,
it can't happen because the
guy's 30 and the girls 16
yeah, come on the go. I agree with you.
Has to died a few guys like the chat.
I agree with you. I was devastated
when the goal that's my virginity to,
it's 16 up with me and I thought I'd
never find love again and I haven't since
really. But I've enjoyed it.
A lot of different women since then.
I just second,
the thing is that's creepy is not the sex,
it's the conversation after six.
It's the fact that he lied there with
her afterwards and wait, how's school?
Thank you and good. And she goes, what
are you been up to? And he is like,
I made a movie.
It's a very good movie, but it's got a
lot of swear words so you can't say it
because you should listen to swear words.
Yeah, that's a good point man. That
is the one thing. That's a good point.
I think that you know, he should be
able to fucking do whatever he wants.
And here's a good looking
guy though, man. You know,
I mean he should be able to a,
I mean he should be able to date
anybody who wants a date him,
as long as that person is old
enough to make their own choice.
The real question is when,
when is the age that you're
old enough to make that choice?
Is it 16 is it 17 is it eight?
It's 16 in the rest of it, but it's
18 oh Geez. Retained in America.
So we mean, so in that sense,
yeah, he broke the law.
But just because some shits written
down on paper obviously doesn't mean it
makes.
And also we know that he broke
other laws such as speeding. Well,
it wasn't like this guy was,
somebody else killed him. He didn't,
he didn't drive that car.
I felt sorry when,
when he died and all that type of stuff.
It was a lot of deaths
all at once this year.
And I felt really sorry for the guy
that made the in Memoriam thing for the
Oscars every night. He must have
sat down and gone. All right. Okay.
The ask is a common Paul Walker,
the gains. Beautiful. I got to bed,
wakes up in the morning. Fucking
Phillip Seymour Hoffman. All right.
Phillip Seymour Hoffman the end.
And then like you read the paper,
I thought Shirley temple was already
dead. This is bullshit. Put Shelly.
She was dead to put Shirley
temple in the end. How old Ram us?
It was just fucking ongoing until
the day he had to make that video.
That guy, uh, James Reb
Horn who, uh, played, uh,
carries dad on a homeland.
He died. I did a,
I did a pilot with that guy. You ever see
that show? Homeland? I do watch homeland.
Who Plays? Who? Harry's Dad. She plays
the, the father of the main chick.
The, the chickens off
of medication. Oh No,
the daughter. Yes. Well, the dad,
the British guy who played
the lead in homeland.
No, no, not that guy. The other
one, Carrie. Carrie is the crazy,
a CIA agent.
Oh, he's all guy. Gray hair just died.
Great Guy. Really,
really, really nice guy.
I was still upset with Fred Phelps.
Thei
tried to, Phillips to me is, if you know,
he's the [inaudible] at
Western Baptist Church.
The Westboro Baptist Church
Guy who used to protest,
guide people's funerals,
soldier's funerals because he believed
that war started because we were too nice
to gaze. It's got a good point. Well,
this is my, this is my thing, but I,
I,
I'm an atheist and I'm also very non
homophobic person in the sense that I,
I uh, I wouldn't even care if my son
was guy. He was loaning. You just have,
I'm of that opinion when it comes
to having sex with, but he was,
Fred Phelps was possibly the most why
out there religious person we've had in a
very long time where he
actually had decisions like,
oh the war started must
be because of the guys.
And then you decide it was gospel.
Right?
But what if he was the only
bloke on earth that was right?
Like he gets to heaven and then God's
like, you're the only one that got me.
And then like God sitting up there,
he goes, where's everyone else?
You guys will no one else.
You're the only person that followed it
to the fucking team and everyone else is
in hell.
And the two of them just sitting there
and gorgeous and then Frager us faggots,
a concept.
They
guard guys damn straight and they fist
pump or something. I don't know. Like if,
if,
if his beliefs were real,
then he's the only black getting
into heaven is the point on made.
Well the problem is his beliefs aren't
anywhere. They're not written anywhere.
Yeah. But he decided to believe
he may have believed them.
If you listen to the way he talks though,
like you ever see the
Eleuthero documentary with
him? We went and visited them,
stay with them for three weeks.
It's very interesting.
And one of the things you realize is
the amount of ego this guy has. Yeah.
And he just wants people to listen to him.
Like he doesn't answer questions sometimes
when when a question comes up he just
says,
I'm not going to even answer that because
you're so stupid.
He just comes up with some
reason why he superior.
There's so much ego involved.
And like what he was doing,
the way he was running that church,
it wasn't based on any scripture.
I liked how they had to sing songs.
You know,
they weren't smart enough
to write their own songs.
So they just got songs of artists
who they probably called sin.
Sin is to begin with. And just the,
there was the one that they did.
We are the world,
but it was like God hates the guy.
They're all [inaudible] and
it's like Michael Jackson,
Lionel Richie, write that song
and you're telling me that,
that you are fans of this.
And I were pretty close to the model
that you wanted for your church or your
paying rights.
Whenever someone is a religious guy and
they try saying in any sort of pop music,
you'd automatically kills it.
Like that guy in Australia that thinks
he's Jesus and he sings green day.
Have you ever seen that guy?
No, he didn't, but I
like, I like him already.
You'd never seen the Australian
Jesus? No. Oh, he's awesome.
He says he's Jesus and he hangs out
with this hot chick that he banks who
apparently used to be Mary
and Mary has a vision.
I'm on the cross. I remember
him. I remember him crying.
I got a quick get a
picture of his cheek or
it's the second check. The one on
the far right is the Mary though.
That's the Jesus with the glasses.
Yeah. Right. And Mary apparently,
unfortunately just found out recently
that she was the second Mary and there was
another girl that Jesus
said was married before her.
Ah,
that was Mary Magdalen.
Yeah. He likes to tell people
he's Jesus to get the pussy.
Oh yeah, I'm Jesus. Yeah. Pain Jesus for
a wall. Really that's his nuclear option.
You've got to listen to it.
You got to talk,
play some it Brian Cause it's quite
brilliant and you know he's not even an
exceptional guy, which is not the Jesus
of Siberia. It's totally different ones.
Yeah,
the faint, this is how the original Jesus
came out and they hung him on a cross.
Like there's got to be some guy. If, if,
if you believe in God and there's
got to be a second coming,
then he's going to cut. These guys got
as much chance as anyone I've been Jesus.
No he doesn't. He has zero chance of
being Jesus. If it's a guy, white guy.
He said he was Jesus as well.
Right.
Well,
he was much like this guy just want to
get some pussy similar listen to them and
they are critical of Miller.
They have, that's not his voice.
That's the narrator's voice.
Um,
his voice though is very non Jesus.
Like
I, I've always been, how
can you be from Australia?
The original Bible didn't
even mention Australia.
Yeah. On Nightline to
the steak. It was like a,
Paul was made the had to tell you that's
not his voice either. He's a Jesus guy.
Was the other guy with the
dark hair and the glasses
fucking do and out of this is
I'd fucking day to, he can't,
if you could see him talking here,
he goes here spirit. Well,
Yup. You can't listen to this.
Here you go. This is one
of Miller's Dick. Okay.
The narrator's wow. Oh
yeah. Quite a bit. Quite
a few. Queensland I believe is where
he lives. Uh, fucking Queensland.
Is that a spot?
That's the,
that's the Alabama of Australia.
Oh, well there you go. That makes sense.
It's a little bit, I actually like
Queensland. My father's from Queensland.
I have an affinity for Queensland.
I'll be there in April,
selling tickets to the Brisbane
Tivoli theater. But um,
I there they're a little bit,
they had a politician for a wall.
They cold Pauline Hanson and Pauline
Hanson was just really racist.
It was like the problems, the aboriginals,
and this is why we have to about a,
you know,
she was one of these type of people.
She got voted in and then town and uh,
and she was sorta these red headed,
what she looked like.
She was off a matchbox. She, she,
she was, sees redheaded woman.
It turned out she had a
electoral fraud and she went to,
she went to prison for like six
months for us to invite him. Anyway,
she comes out after being really racist,
like,
and then saying stupid things like how
would you fix the economy and she goes,
print more money.
Then we'd all have more money.
Like this is the level of intelligence.
Jesus Christ, she got voted in, right?
So she's like another level path. Sarah
Palin, even in my family, we were like,
that woman's disgusting. I
can't believe that. All these
things. He's like, yeah, no,
she's, she's a rice as Sarah Pylon. That's
a perfect, that's what I'm on. Right.
And so she gets put into prison
and then when she comes out,
she goes on dancing with the stars.
Right.
And my parents forgive.
My parents will forgive anything
if you do a cracking foxtrot,
like they're watching that they were
voting for her God, because my is,
she's got good legs. I got, but she just
said that aboriginal should die. Ah,
he bloody hold on to things for too long.
That's so true.
Someone was running for president and
they did star search or dancing with the
stars or American idol or whatever
those fucking shows are. And you know,
we're American got to vote
and they did really well.
They'd probably become president.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Hi. If she,
let's see if we can get a
picture of Pauline Hanson up.
I haven't had a look at this
woman's face for going on 20 years.
She's done a fish and chip shop.
There was like people that she was so
racist people would where Martin Luther
King tee shirts on the front that said,
I have a dream and then there'd be a
picture of her on the back of it goes,
I have a fish and chip shop.
There she is.
That was that Sarah pilot in Australia.
Well, she even kind of has that thing
going on. That Sarah Palin thing going on.
Yeah. And the Asians, the Asians
come in here and buy all the land.
Wow. What do you think about these whole
banning bossy? You got retarded, stupid.
Never going to work, but
me, it makes me angry.
It makes me angry that you pretending
that someone's feelings are hurt because
you have the word bossy.
They tried,
they said the word bossy
means leadership ship.
It doesn't like, I have a few nieces
and I won't say which of them.
One of them's bit bossy and when I'm
in Bossy, it's not like she goes, okay,
you sit over here, we're playing this
game. She's like, don't touch that.
That's my toy. She's just
a bit of a con. Yeah,
they don't like Conti.
So they're trying to get rid of Bossy,
which is a substitute for Conti.
They're trying to remove themselves from
criticism or anybody who's coming up
with that.
They're either trying to silence free
speech or they're trying to remove what
they think is criticism and they
faced many times and it's, you know,
a lot of them. Like what,
where's it coming from? Most
likely feminists and well,
what are a lot of feminists?
A lot of feminists are very strong women
who like being able to tell people what
the fuck to do and what, what would be
a criticism of that? Well, she's a con,
she's Conti, she's bossy. Those are there.
They're all in line with what's what
people don't like. I will ban Bossy,
get the fuck, am I in frame
his speech, he campaign,
it's fuck this thing
on their advert or the program.
The woman was there going,
do you know that men earn
99% of the world's property?
Right. And I, and then
I, I thought about it,
do you know 95% of the
homeless are also men?
This is plenty of Bossy bitches kicking
cans out of the houses I live in rent
free are nice guy.
All you ban Bossy,
you won't get women that
are heads of corporations.
Most bossy women that I've
known in my life don't have jobs
and probably would never get to the head
of a corporation because that requires
a lot of people skills. It's not like they
have been held back, bicycling, Bossy,
I'm there paying the rent and they're
still fucking bossing me around. You know?
It doesn't feel like, yeah, no,
this, the idea is ridiculous.
The idea that all these women want to
have fucking want to be the head of
corporations is ridiculous too. A lot
of women don't want those jobs either.
They're not working towards those jobs.
The idea that they're completely
banned from those jobs.
There are women out there
who run corporations. Is it
fair? I'm not saying it is,
but there's a lot of shit that's not fair.
My life is not fair. Will most, well,
there's a good chance we'll have a
female president next or possible. Yeah.
There's just very different
characteristics that
men have and women have.
It's very different personalities,
almost inherent to having testosterone
and a Dick, but you don't have,
it was a with the woman
and this is nothing against
women when they have a kid.
I'm not saying cause they take
nine months out of the workplace,
although it's probably a problem, but I
didn't give a fuck when they have a kid,
their mind does change a little bit.
They become less career driven for
a lot of them. Not all of them,
but they do start going, I want to
spend time with this and Dah Dah Dah.
And then a man has to step up a
little bit more and work a bit. Huh.
I sometimes big garage,
the amount I have to go on the road
and be away from my kids. So I was,
I can support the family. You know, I
feel like I miss out on something there.
I'd rather be home all the time with him.
Right. I know exactly what you mean. Um,
I think everyone has a role and that
everyone's role is different depending on
the relationship, depending on where you
are in life, depending on everything.
But the idea that it would should be
even for men and women is ridiculous.
The idea that anything
should be even as ridiculous.
The only thing you should ask is for
no discrimination, no discrimination,
and that someone will be there,
there'd be promoted based entirely
on how well they do what they do.
Here's what the idea that,
yeah,
but the idea that like there should be
an equal amount of men and an equal out
of women in the same
position that I don't buy.
That doesn't make any sense to me
because there's a lot of jobs that men do
better than women and a lot of
jobs that women do better than men.
It's just a fact.
And they've got Beyonce
and Congolese arise.
And who is the other bird that got a
Giulia? God is on the campaign as well.
And then like Beyonce is dead
going, going, uh, I'm not bossy,
but I am the boss. I'm the queen.
What is it with black women?
And wanting to be the coin queen.
Latifa. Amen. The coin of the night.
Men.
Men are always the king.
Black men like this is a lot of fighters
that call themselves king black.
All white men will call
themselves the king of the castle.
I'm the king of my home.
That's a universal mile
thing. We want to be the king.
Black women want to be queens and
watch six want wanna be princesses.
It's true, right? They don't even
want to be Queens. The only child
shake that wants to be
the queen is the queen.
Every,
every time you made a girl,
I want to be have a princess because
they want to be taken care of and black
chicks alike.
I want to fucking own you.
God, I'm the Queen. Well,
that was the thing that
black men like the,
there was a big thing they used to say.
It was that we used to be kings. You know,
black man used to be kings. You know,
before we were slaves, we were king.
God, I rarely I little villages
and they didn't travel very far.
It was easy to be a king
when the population was 10
and it was you and the other
hot and you're like I'm queen or whatever
and fucking you go out with your spear
and you think, oh I'm the king of
this little tea cause it's still,
now they've got guys that are
driving taxis in the UK who was like,
I'm Prince of Dubai. Bubububuh
right. And you're like,
I'm fourth in line for the throne and
there's so many fucking kings over there.
That's hilarious.
And it's so true.
If you really stop and think
about it like the, the,
the amount of people that's
probably directly in line.
We were talking about and we
were talking about being famous,
that you don't want to be the king of
a place. It's too big. Yeah. You know,
like you don't want to be the
[inaudible] either had a Rome,
there's too much shit going on.
Even all these other countries be able
to overthrow. Yeah. Too much stress.
Everybody's looking to
kill you all the time.
But if you're the king of a fucking
small village, Eh, like you probably do,
I'm pretty good. He'd get all
the fish. Yeah, you're good.
You got 10 wives or
whatever the hell you need.
You gotta go and wives.
Occasionally you can go over to a
guy's house and just take a goat.
Yeah, it's a, it's a tribute who has to
pay, but if you'd like to head of England,
God damn is a lot of pressure on you.
Well, that king. Yeah, that was a good
film. I love, you know what
I like about King Ralph?
King Ralph is a movie where you know
they've worked backwards. They've gone.
All right. This is the prep.
You've come up with movie ideas.
Whenever you go with movie ideas,
you think of just the broad strokes.
So someone's going, okay, American guy
is the king of England and he's a Slob,
and he likes 10 pin bowling.
All right, that's what I've got.
And then another guy's going, how do we
get rid of the royal family? I'm fuck.
I'm thinking, all right. And then
one of them is gone. I've got it.
They're all standing in a
puddle and get a lecture.
They're all similar.
They had take a photo of the entire
or family at once they're there,
they're standing in a bit of water,
the camera, it goes, falls over, light,
falls into the puddle and
they all get electric,
electrified the death ls electrified,
and then obviously they
go through all the family,
like can't find a single relative until
they find a fat guy from Milwaukee
called Ralph.
I don't know if he's from Milwaukee.
It sounds like he was king graph.
I never saw that movie.
Peter I told was it was a good painter.
I told,
it's funny, I haven't seen
it. Have you seen it recently?
I tell you what I know and movies.
I tell you what I watched three
days ago I watched the doors movie,
great fucking movie.
I don't know because I went and saw it
when I was [inaudible] 99 three or 1992
when that movie came out,
I saw it in the cinema so that would've
made me 16 I was a kid from Australia.
I had never heard a doors song,
but I knew it was hip to like the doors.
And so I went along and watched it and
it was all of a stone is a lot of cutting
back and forth and all this type of stuff.
And I remember walking out of the cinema
being bought out of my skull at 15,
but then like still signed to my
friends. Like that was a cool movie, man,
they're lying.
And then when I had,
then when I heard like someone
didn't like the film, I was like,
you obviously didn't get it.
You obviously don't get what
Jim Morrison has to say.
And now I watched it as an adult and
it's not as a, I enjoyed it more.
But my conclusion was that Jim
Morrison was a bit of a Dick.
He was definitely a bit of a Dick,
but he was also a guy,
just like we were talking about with,
uh, when we're talking about Lenny Bruce,
he's living in a totally different era,
like breaking out in that era,
like doing what they were doing.
How many,
how many young Canadians have you met
the think they like a gym. Like a, yeah,
the things I'm saying and the
words I'm, you know. Yeah.
You ever worked the punchline
Atlanta? Uh, yes, I have. Yes.
Back Room. The green room has
a, someone wrote on the wall,
quit trying to be Hicks.
That's fucking brilliant.
It's brilliant because for a long time,
like especially after Hicks died when he
died in the UK, that's all I care about.
The heat stopped man. Yeah. And
I've actually, I like Bill Hicks,
but I've gone out of my way not to
watch him because I got kind of sick of
anytime you did edgy comedy
you've got compared to him.
And I thought if I don't watch him
and you can't compare because I'm not
influenced, so I haven't,
you know what I mean? But,
well, that's a compliment. I don't think
people are meaning in a negative way.
Yeah, no, no. But it's,
it just got to the stage where evidently
we were all trying to be Bill Hicks.
Yeah. That's just an easy
criticism. That's like,
if you have an argument with a woman
and someone say, Oh, you hate women.
You hate all women. Like, you know,
you know that easy argument, you know,
and if you're, you're edgy and
they want to dismiss you, oh,
you're just trying to be
hex [inaudible] dismissal.
My girlfriend's favorite argument is when
I'm telling her off about something is,
or when she's telling me or
whatever the argument is,
is the problem with you is you always
think you're right. And I always go,
did you say things that you think are
wrong? Is this what you fucking do?
Of course, I always think are
Mariah. Oh, I might not be right,
but these are my opinions. These are
what I therefore believe to be correct.
You just fucking sign things willy nilly.
So this is probably why we fought so much.
But yeah, I always believe him. Right?
I think if you consider it deeply enough,
you should always believe you're right.
Yeah. Yeah. If you're just talking
off the top of your head. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. I, I, I might be an
idiot, but I always think I'm right.
Yeah. I don't ever say anything that
I think is wrong. Several Times,
four times I am wrong.
But I don't know that before the fight.
That's a very important point
that you don't know you're wrong,
but you are if someone's, but that I
have a real problem with that. When,
when someone realizes in the middle of
an argument that the wrong keep going.
No, when they keep going. That's what I,
I fucking hate that when you
hear him justifying it back then
is I was unset Dajay calls it in my shows,
the skinny kid out of the road trip I was,
he was singing along to a wanted
dead or alive by Bon Jovi.
I'm on it data La.
And then there's the line on
the steel horse I ride, right?
Yeah. I always thought it was,
I'm going to steal the whole,
so I ride because he's a cowboy,
right?
It tends that he's riding on a motorcycle
and I haven't got the gist of this
song whatsoever. Right. And I
said, Oh, you got that wrong.
I'm going to steal the horse, our
rod. And then he said, no, it's not.
And then I went, Nah, you wrong. I checked
it on the Internet and he was right,
but I didn't back down.
[inaudible]
it's going for weeks about it.
You don't even know fucking song lyric
sticks is gone. You would upset him.
Either one is fine. Steel horse
or steal the horse. I think steel,
the horse is more renegade.
Cowboy steal horses.
Any asshole can go buy a Harley Davidson.
I like, I like my lyrics better.
It's better. It is better steel. The horse
I ride. That's some real renegade shit.
You're a fucking euro.
You're a horse thief.
There's a song.
One of my favorite songs when Australian
Bank would you and why is called a
heavy hot and uh,
uh,
there's a lyric that goes,
now every tee shirts
got a white wine stain.
I'm loving cigarettes again.
I know every June,
it's just about a guy been dumped right
now. Every teacher has got a Weinstein.
I always thought it was, now every teacher
has a white stain and that's my legs.
Cause like he's been dumped.
So he's winking so much,
getting come everywhere.
And I think that's probably
better in a romantic song though.
Teesha it's got a wide stain. I'm
loving secret restaurant Game Weinstein.
Come on now. Hold me closer Tony.
Danza yeah, that's a good, yeah.
Everybody used to have a bit about that.
And there was like one of
the early standup bits that
people used to have a bit
about people getting the, the, the
lyrics wrong. There was a bunch of guys
where they used to have like the sheet
where they haven't written and they'd be
flipping over what they thought was right.
No, no, no, no. Like they
would sing the wrong lyrics.
Like there's a few guys that had bits
and it would be a real problem if they
work together.
Like there's a few guys that had bits
about people getting the wrong Lucy in the
sky with diamonds. I
would come up with an, uh,
the wrong word for it and
they would have a whole thing.
I saw a lot of guys hold me close,
a tiny dancer and chunk.
That's Photoshop though. So, obviously
I, there was a, um, uh, there,
there was a lot of guys, you would have
a pad and they'd ride up in Britain.
They'd write out all the lyrics
to songs like a, you know,
like that's something that was
probably like in satanic movies.
It's in Latin. Right. But he would write
out what he thought it was an English.
And then when you saw the words with
the music, he started to go, oh,
that is what they're saying, you know?
And then there was another one for that.
Michael Jackson, the Earth Song. What
about pat? What about us? That one,
no one knows what the fuck he's saying
and that he's just screaming around.
And that was very popular in Britain
for them to go, oh, these are the words.
I think it's, yeah, it's kind of hacky.
It's kind of hacky. Yeah. But I'm not,
I don't mind a guy.
There's occasionally you'd get like this
song parody guys that are really shit,
most of them is shit. But occasionally
you'll get a guy where you go, oh,
he's all right. Him just out
of nowhere. It's like anything,
if you, if you, if you,
even if you do something shit,
if you do it extraordinarily well,
that it can be good.
Well,
it sucks for a guide like weird Al
Yankovic who was like one of the first guy
who does it. He does it very good
and just doesn't change the lyrics.
He gives a whole new story. It's
like he does that, uh, that, that,
uh, um, offs, offspring song.
I'm pretty fly for a rabbi
and it's just all about this
guy and he's in, he's in,
he's rabbi plays and he's
in a synagogue and you know,
it is a weird thing.
No one,
someone else creates the foundation
for what you're doing. You know,
whenever you're doing
a parody of something,
someone else creates a foundation and
then you come along and build comedy on
the foundation of whatever they're doing.
Like, I'm fat from, I'm bad. You know,
you were at to
get the same outfit on
first guy to really,
uh,
he used to get the rights from people
like for the film clips and everything.
People were used to like
it when they did it. Oh,
I'm sure at the moment I've been told
that Dana Carvey does an impersonation of
me.
I desperately want to see it.
Dana Carvey doesn't impersonation.
Yeah,
like it's CIA.
The agents we said we just had done in
coffee doesn't impersonation of you were
all cracking up and I
think he does it on stage,
but he was just doing it for the other
agents down at sea and then I think they
thought that I'd be like, what the
fuck is that? Can't do. And I was like,
fuck all I want to know and how it
is what it looks like I want to,
I want to see. Then it can be, he's
like one of the best impersonators ever.
Yeah, that's, that's cool.
That's cool that he's doing
an impersonation. Yeah. Wow.
That's a good sign.
That's a good sign. Yeah. He's,
he's one of these guys that I always
think maybe he just didn't want to do
movies anymore because you just
leave it up in San Francisco now.
He plays clubs every weekend and stuff
like that, but does he? Yeah. I thought,
I think as you do a lot of stand up.
Yeah,
but I think he does it like in a club
down the road from his house where he goes
every week and it's packed out. You know
what I mean? Like he's just that guy.
What's fine out. Yeah. He was, I think
he was at the Ice House recently. Really?
Aye. Aye Man. He's
[inaudible] films where like,
like Wayne's world know that we're
like a big deal for me. Yeah, me too.
I think I saw Wayne's world
more than any movie ever.
My life. Oh, he's doing
a bunch of theaters.
He's doing a San well casino and he's
doing the Ip casino resort and spies doing
like, you know, smaller casinos.
But maybe he's doing, you know,
he just mostly works up there and then
I wa I want to put him in legit. I'll
say a fee. If we get a third season.
I don't want to put him in. I am
doing an impression of you. Yeah.
Maybe that could be the reason.
Like I can see him on TV doing in person.
They send me, I go to confront him or
something. It would be a cool episode.
Like if I was a bit arrogant and all upset
and I was on coke when I was watching
the episode where he was
doing that or the TV spot.
I think for a guy like him,
you know,
I bet it's probably really a nice thing
to do to just be able to do theaters.
Yeah. Just do his gig on the weekends
and then go places and not having anybody
telling him, you know, Oh our
movie got funded. Uh, the,
the production company wants to
change something about your show or
it's like, it's like my PR person
wanted to come along to me with this,
cause I didn't book it and went, Oh, we
should come along to everything. I'm like,
I've done Joe's podcast before.
Just fine getting there by myself.
Oh,
pay PR people are disgusting when people
bring him and they start talking to me.
Um, you know, like what, what he
needs to do is if the fuck outta here,
get the fuck outta here. You can't talk
for him. What did that let that guy,
there's a reason why he's here
and not you. He's, he's a talker.
This is a comedian or
she or whoever the fuck,
it's a very odd occupation.
The Po,
because they're confused everybody
else that you have employed,
you can sort of exactly tell where the
money's coming from. Your agent books,
the gigs and you manage it gets you to,
you can sorta go quintessential. You.
You can justify that, but with
PR it's just like, I dunno.
Is that worth the money? I don't know.
I did. I did. I get anything out of it.
Is My life better? I don't. I'm
not sure what happened there.
Some of them are real good. Some of
them are really good at it. You know,
I have a good publicist.
He gets it like if I need to do things,
he can get me those things here.
I want to promote something
to Gig or what have you,
but the bad ones are the ones that tell
the clients what to say and what to do
and where to don't don't talk about
this. Remember, don't don't do this.
Don't do that. You can ever do that
with a comic, comics should do.
Most likely the mistake that you think
that they're going to make would be one
of the best things they could do. Like
you telling them not to say something.
If they wind up saying it
and it becomes hilarious,
a big uproar and the network gets pissed.
It's probably the best
thing they could ever do.
I got in trouble yesterday,
a couple of weeks ago,
and Opie and Anthony just ringing in and
I had to have my publicist check that I
didn't fuck everything up in my life
because Carrie fishes in the season,
it legit.
And so I chatted to Carrie Fisher for a
wall and Carrie Fisher told me a little
bit about what she was doing and star
wars and I didn't think it was a big
secret.
And I was talking to him.
What was it
like on Star Wars for homes and web pages?
Went fucking mental look.
Jim Jefferies just spilled the beans on
the new star wars, Phil. Oh, not at all.
I was like, ah, fuck this.
The last fucking bit of Mafia in
this town that I need going after me.
The people who were in charge of tis
and 20th century Fox and Disney once
teaming up to ruin my career.
So she told you a secret nerd?
She didn't give me a big check. He, oh,
she said, well, she said, ah. She said,
said to me, she goes, Oh, I'm gonna film
star wars sort of January through to July.
And I sit on Opie and Anthony. I
go, wow. And it was nasty. I got,
she kind of helped you having a small
role because she's there for that many
months.
So like I imagine that that we got to see
her Luke Skywalker and Han Solo in the
whole film, you know, which,
which many people were speculating
that they'll just have a cameo. Right.
And I was saying,
well that amount of time,
and I thought maybe this was
information that everyone already knew.
I didn't know that I was,
I had some secret,
I can say it again here
because I'm already in trouble.
Right. She was the one who
fucked up by telling you, you're going to
tell someone something. That's a secret.
You've got to say, hey, you
can't tell anybody this.
Well,
I didn't know if it was a secret.
I don't know if it's just
been blown out of proportion,
but they say that episode seven is a
continuation of episode six. I'm like,
Eh, it's got to have to be a
38 gap between these things.
Unless something happened with the
force where everyone I age really fast.
They lost me 100% a few years back.
It's like the first couple of star wars,
the for the original few,
pretty good.
And then when they took that gap and then
came back was in the eighties the late
eighties when they
started doing them again
because the phantom menace
was a lighter than that man.
That was like 19 no, 2000 I was
at university. Was it really?
Yeah.
Okay. Well, wherever it was, I was
like, man, this is just not star wars.
That was the height of my ecstasy
taking and I, I was that stupid thing.
When you get so into pills
where you're like, oh,
we're going to see star wars and we'll
be on ecstasy because it's like someone's
just spent $1 billion in special effects
and that's still not good enough for my
mind anymore. I need to see it. What is
it like to see that movie on ecstasy?
Do you forgive them more?
I saw it.
The phone I started the first
time I'd actually to see,
and I remember saying to
people as we walked out,
best star wars ever when I
went and saw it two more times,
and also it didn't like adjust after the
drugs wore off because I'd been telling
everyone all that week,
you've got to see it.
It's better than the original star
wars is. Oh No. Cause the pod cast,
the Pod, the pod thing, not the podcast.
The pod racing blew my fucking mind.
Charter banks,
he is awesome and I smell an Oscar to
remember how bad that character was.
Everybody was angry. You know, always
bad about those new films where,
and I don't know if George is just
an idiot, but little bit racist,
a little jar jar Binks was obviously
like a black sort of slave woman from a,
like a gone with the wind style fill and
a black actor. Yeah, pull up the jar,
jar Binks. But the way
he talk video, Misa,
Misa gonna to help you out to me said,
and he was like, just fucking Sean,
my shoes and fuck off. Like it was that
level of racism that we're putting in it.
And then they made the, the guys
who were the trade embargo people,
they will like Nazi s Japanese people.
They were like,
you have no section here in this
part of the galaxy like that.
Right. Hold up a video, pull up a video.
I want to hear you do it. Yeah, no, it's,
it's uh, my bell or whatever.
Well that's interesting man.
I never even thought about it. And then
the goodies all had British accent,
all the jet noise.
We're like,
we have hosted the realm of the things
we do today and then you'll cannot come
into our 20 [inaudible]. Right. So
it was like an all the, all the,
all the gang guns were like light back.
Jim, Mike installed black people in the,
in the end of the film where
they were all like hippies.
Just did is that thing that we do when
we have a language that we want to be
noble,
we give it an English accent or villains.
They're good at villains or romantic
leads, English accent. When you hear
why is this music playing in
the background? Cause there's,
I think most of the videos would charge
our banks has been taken off for you too.
But this one's awesome.
Misa Misa,
Robin
stepping on dog,
he always has to walk 10
steps behind this whole weird,
the music is killing me.
He was the first like fully CGI
person in cinema in the technology.
Just was a few years off because then
they sort of nailed it with Gollum.
Well they can make it, the thing about
these guys like George our banks is,
it's not a real thing.
So you don't compare it to a real
thing and it doesn't fuck with you.
Like a real lion looks way
different than a CGI line.
Oh yeah.
The way they move it's like,
but like Godzilla is probably
going to look fucking bad.
Ass Lizards and stuff looked really good.
But I,
I always say don't CGI clothes.
As soon as you did CGI clothing on
[inaudible] the material doesn't flows to
smoothly. Like it's water or something.
It doesn't ruffle like a real shirt.
Like Yoda look cool as a puppet.
He was more believable as a up
cause he existed. Yes. And now Yoda,
it's like with these flowing cloak
that he comes in with, it just doesn't,
that's what takes me out of it.
Yeah.
That's the argument that special effects
guys have for using makeup and like
Richard, you know like the, the, the,
the type of special effects
that they used in star wars.
The original star wars
saw like the same shit.
They use an American Werewolf in London,
like rubber and you know,
hair and they the, it's all special
effects guys, but it's really,
Rick Baker was like the main
guy. But yeah, it's a real thing.
Whereas like if you're looking at
hair is a big one, like flowing hair,
any flowing hair with CGI looks like shit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's not, yeah,
unless it's like in a CGI world,
like a Pixar film where everyone's
fucking, exactly. Yeah. Like A,
it's standing next to another
person. You're like, Eh,
it's not real. Yeah. It's
not, they're not ready yet.
Animals are not ready at the
wolves and game of Thrones,
those dire wolves or like
we got, uh, we got John
Ratzenberger on the sh on my show.
He plays one of the dads, right.
Cliff climbing from cheese. Ah, great.
Now I can always tell the age of a girl,
like,
I don't cheat on my girlfriend anything.
But I always think if when
these girls were extras,
I have one light on the thing.
I always, you always think,
I wonder if I could have fucked
her. You know, that's our whole,
all your life is like this.
Right, right. Of course.
I was talking to one go thinking thing
and she was cute and then this is the way
I gauge a girl,
whether she's too young for me where the,
when she's talking to John Ratzenberger
does she know him as I cliff from cheese
or be the pig from toy story
and as she's never heard of
cheers and he goes, oh yeah,
mammy the pig from toy story.
Yeah.
I get them quick buzz Lightyear
if he does all that and they go,
oh I know who you are. You Go, okay, you
can't go near that girl that's too young.
Okay
so young. It's like actually
you must have seen cheese once.
A lot of people haven't. You
know why? Cause kids did.
I don't see anything old because
they've got too many channels options.
It's true new shows to catch up on.
I used to see every,
I seen all the advocates size,
Maren
impact kettle films,
Everly Shirley temple movie.
Cause my mother liked these old black
and white films and they were on a Sunday
and we only had four
channels in the one TV.
So I had to fucking sit and
watch these films. Right.
Because I didn't go out of the House
for whatever reason. Now the kids today,
they've got their own, you know,
you got to wake up for a cartoon.
Remember you had to the cartoon, was
it Sunday? You had to wake up for it.
I remember that Shit.
Now you can DVR it.
Plus you've got a cartoon channel and
then when you get a bit older you've got
this channel. It's sort of caters
to you being a fucking moron.
The Nickelodeon one where it's like
now like you're grown up a little bit.
We're still going to keep your children
when the kids should be stopped watching
more adults sort of dry
already type things.
There's now they're watching fucking
Miley Cyrus or Hannah Montana or all that
type of shit.
Have you ever seen nick at nite
or Nick Moms? They have nick.
Nick Mom's stand after
dark. Yeah, they're,
they have the mum's doing stand
up about being a mom. Yeah.
I guess it works for them, you know,
I'm not hating or anything but,
but it seems like a
very restrictive thing.
It's like I once did an atheist convention
in front of like 5,000 people in
Australia and I was booked to do it.
And as I said,
why Uttama jags after they'd done this
is the only time I brought back old jokes
in recent times because I
had to do a 40 minutes set.
It had to be all religious stuff and I
have 40 minutes or religious stuff over
the course of all my specials.
Yeah. But never at one.
So I actually sat on looking
myself up on youtube going, oh,
that's how that bit goes. All right,
let's have a bit. That'd be great.
So I could just do a
religious fucking set.
A 40 minute religious set. Yeah.
How do you keep yourself from your,
like repeating the same sort of a theme?
Wow. Well, I've done a
lot of religious books,
but there was a little bit of cheating
going on in the sense that I'd go,
I'd go a fucking, these Catholics
don't like people wearing condoms,
do they? Anyway? I fucked
a chick without a condom.
[inaudible] wasn't a religious routine,
but there was some definite,
yeah,
there was some dressing up of other
jokes to make them look like they were
religious. That's funny. But when you do,
when you meet that many atheists guy,
the atheist community,
not a good looking bunch. Not a lot
of sexy atheists. I don't know why.
A lot of redundancy to la and as I said
at my opening line was look at this
5,000 people talking about nothing
like this is a lot of effort
to talk about nothing.
Well, if you ever heard of
atheism plus, what's that? Oh,
this is where it gets rough.
It's atheism plus a set of
core ethical and moral values.
So it's like, you know,
antidiscrimination antiracism atheist,
like essentially it's a religion,
a religion based on a
type of anti religion,
but you still know how to do these things.
You should have your own code
inherently in you as a human being.
I call it de, yeah, atheism.
Pluses, Duh, Duh. Don't be racist.
Duh.
Don't be homophobic.
I think it's certain point in time when
enough interest information gets like,
okay, like for instance this group, okay,
the four people that are in this room,
if you want to start preaching to
the four people in this room that you
shouldn't be homophobic or
you shouldn't be racist.
Like to us with no point other than just
espousing your beliefs. We'd be like,
Duh. Of course with the fuck he's
saying, unless there's some humor to it.
You just repeating some shit that
everybody with a fucking brain and a heart
agrees with. Like why? Why would you
be sexist? Why would you be homophobic?
Why would you
all this symbol.
Simple fundamental things that that
decide whether you can be friends with a
person. Just the the, the bit where
these are deal breakers for me.
If you're a homophobic
or racist or whatever,
I think you're a cock if
you're any of these things.
And then there's the other
things like I'm anti gun.
I have a lot of people who are pro gun,
you know what I mean?
That's something that's just open
to fucking argument on the bipolar.
It's not a deal closer when it comes
to being a friend. Right? Absolutely.
And then, yeah, and then we
of course, we all hate women.
We're all on the same page with that one.
Right.
The antidepressant one is one that I,
I leave open to debate.
I have people that I'm friends with that
we'll go on this big rants about how
evil antidepressants are.
And then I have friends that are on them.
Oh, I've, I've used them and I've
found that have helped me in my life.
You used them and you got off of
them? Yes. Why did you get off of him?
I probably should stay on them,
but I'm of the opinion in life,
it's better to be taking nothing into
your body. Medicine wise. You know,
there's other things you should take,
vitamins or whatever,
but I feel like if you can get
away with it and not take it,
it's probably better in the long term.
Have you ever fucked around with five
HTP? What's that? Five HTP is, um,
it's the building blocks
for Serotonin and you,
you could take it in a supplement form
and five HTP actually helps your body
produce more Serotonin,
makes you feel better.
Alright. I'd be definitely up
for something like that. I, uh,
for me it's,
I've been on any depression sometimes
there was some that was a big tragic event
happening in my life
and I could just have,
may have to pull my shit together a
couple of times that have happened in the
last time I was,
I was just suffering from depression
and it just wasn't fucking shifting.
You know, I've been hitting
head. Yeah. How many times? Um,
one major.
So like high school a few times,
but one major time as an adult like this,
there's a infamous video of
me getting punched on stage,
but that one didn't actually hurt.
That was just a little dinger.
But one time I got off stage a Nottingham,
England and no hint that the Gig had gone
badly or heckles or anything like that.
And a guy came up and grabbed me from the
back of their head and smashed my head
into a table and I fractured my
skull above the bridge of my nose.
Why did he do that? I, I'm never
quite sure I was knocked out,
like put the rest of the
guide. Um, from what I heard,
the security roughed him up and the
British government gave me $10,000 in
conference. I 10,000 pounds
in compensation. But you
got unconscious, Huh?
And I wake up in the hospital. Yeah.
Fuck that one. It was like one of these,
one hit is,
but also I was facing the
other direction and it was,
it was really a, and this is what
I was saying, cause I ain't look,
this is one of the debates are getting,
I'm all for public health care and I'm
saying that as someone who's got money
and would pay for my private health care
on top of that. Anyway, uh, in Britain,
man, they put me in a hospital. They
never checked one name. They might. Sure.
I was, oh, fucking well and good.
And then they just left me and
I wasn't a citizen or nothing.
I agree with you 100% I
think that healthcare should
be mandatory that society
takes care of its citizens. Yeah, I think
there should be optional healthcare,
like a really good doctor,
you know,
like to get your knee fixed
or something like that.
You want to go to the
guy who does the Lakers,
but everyone should be
able to get healthcare.
The the, the poor people in society
should have free health care.
And when I said the poor people,
like people, like students,
even if you come from a
rich family or whatever,
but once you're on your own at 18 and you
want to stand on your own two legs and
you don't want to ring mom and
dad up and go, moo, moo new book,
you know what I mean?
They should be taken care of.
And then once you get a bit like,
normally when you get money,
it's lighter in life and you have
more islands later in life anyway.
But in the UK, I paid for my
private health care on top
of my normal health care.
Now if the public health healthcare,
if I had something small,
I used to use the public health k just
to see a GP or the emergency room or
whatever. I just sold my thing. And
then if they said like I had to,
like for instance, I had a cyst in my neck
that had to be cut out and the doctor,
when the doctor goes,
all right,
you can be put on the waiting
list for the public health care.
You can get it done in four weeks or I
can do it for you tomorrow if you use
your private cover. So you get
moved up the ladder quicker. Right.
So at least people who were
complaining and American look,
Oh and get as much help if you still
buy and on top, that's a better system.
And then nothing changes. But it's, it's,
I don't think they've structured it
brilliant. Yeah. He or maybe they've had,
they've been up against it trying to
explain it to Americans because I listened
to people on the radio all the time who
had just like, who sound poor to me.
They sound like they're working class
people who kind of, and they are like,
I don't want these healthcare, these self
care is going to, and you're like, what?
You don't want what you
don't want to have. Like
the whole fact that these companies
won't cover existing conditions.
If you have a little child that's
born with aids or whatever and,
and it's a very like exact thing of
just say it, but of course someone,
they should have health care.
Exactly. You know there should be certain
core things that society takes care of.
There should be law enforcement,
there should be hospitals
just to be fire departments.
When those core things are
not being taken care of,
if you don't have health care for,
for people,
I mean the w what's the point in
having a society like what you can't,
if you can't give these people the
ability to heal themselves. I mean,
isn't that like one of the
major things you would,
let's take care of people's heads.
Not In the constitution,
but in the constitution.
It was written when health care was shit.
What the fuck they were doing chicken
bones and fucking didn't even have
bandaids. How about that?
They didn't have bandaids.
They didn't have sticky shit yet.
It leaches were very,
very in that that's how
people thought you'd heal.
They didn't know enough about bodies.
But the whole idea that we have to
stick only buy things that were in the
constitution.
The world is so fucking
radically different than it
was in the 17 hundreds and
the I, the idea is just fucking
stupid. It's just a stupid idea.
The constitution has some great ideas
and a great understanding of what goes
wrong when corruption
commandments. It's a good foundation
and a base, but then you can add to it.
And then, you know, what did Louis
Ck say that uh, there's no, the, the,
the 10 commandments don't say you can't
rife. Well, rapists kind of
tolerate it in the Bible.
And when her second class
citizens in the Bible,
I mean it's so clearly flavored
by the time in which people, uh,
wrote it. I mean there's a lot of
fucking shit and the Bible though,
when you were there,
talk about coveting that wives neighbor
that's not about fucking are wanting to
fucker. It's about she's
property. That's what it is.
It's like taking his property.
It's not like coveting his wife,
you know it will because they're in love.
When you got the GIG
vice and over a tit,
you're going to like calm it.
I'll put it on yet.
Great grasp of the English language. Well
I don't think most people do. All right.
My neighbor's wife though was about
him being, you know, him owning her.
Yay Slaves.
It's they,
they have all these laws about in the
Bible about beating your slaves. It's all
written about wherever the guy was.
And we did a five mile radius. Is it?
There's a webpage could ask God or
something with little kids can type in and
the most asked question and ask God is
this is what kids brains work like kids
want to know where they
kangaroos on the Ark.
All right,
hear all the stories a child can get the
Bible down to this is the information I
want. Where are the Kangaroos in
the arc is the most asked question.
And the answer is uh, although there was
no mention of Kangaroos in the Bible,
you can be assured because there was
two of each animal that there were
kangaroos on the air.
They just decided to leave it out
because not a lot of Australians read the
Bible.
No, they just left it out because they
didn't fucking know about Australia.
God made God made the entire earth and
the universe and all that type of stuff.
And he did it in like a week,
but a didn't know about it.
Australia,
at least not to mention in his book,
the Australia thing is very interesting
because it's such a huge continent and
there's all these animals that are
specific to Australia, like the kangaroo.
Those motherfuckers aren't anywhere else.
No,
I'm fucking wombats
on the Yak.
And when Noah finished,
when the water was going down
or when the water was receding,
like to where it is now,
legal and drop everyone off
at their different places did,
it might be all these animals were rocking
around, whatever the that he was in,
they all
lived in this one town and then you went,
oh, this is all the animals we got left.
I'm going to touch your garden.
Australia. Y'All gone astray. Paula Bays,
you all going to be on this bike
for a wall. Uh, lions. Africa,
like he must have decided,
right?
Is there a bit in the Bible
where he decides no one,
they all walked and they found
their spots on the world.
Yeah. How, how did they
make it to Australia?
God provided them walking
on water abilities.
They gave him these big shoes that you
have on holidays that you think you're
good when you're going to walk on the
walk on water. Tennis racket shoes. Yeah.
Those ones,
those are snow shoes.
They, you need those man. If
you actually go walk in snow,
if you were watching those a Alaska shows
where people live and you from sinking
or yeah,
they have these giant like you know sort
of like net looking shoes and they walk
around on those fucking
things and it keeps you from,
it spreads out your weight
over a large period.
A large a space keeps you from like if
you were on pegs walking through the snow
would be a real fucking pain in the ass.
Stilts would be not good.
Like you don't want a wide tire
when you drive it in the snow.
A lot of people think that you don't get
more traction if you had a wide tire.
Yeah,
you actually want a more narrow tire
because the narrow tire cuts through the
snow. The big wide tires tend to float
on it because there's more weight is
distributed over a larger patch,
a larger pattern.
I don't really understand the snow.
I find it.
I find it weird whenever I go play a Gig,
like I was just in this week,
I was in Milwaukee and Detroit.
It was snowing in both places and I'm
there in the snow and I feel like telling
the people, you know, you're
allowed to live anywhere in America.
You're a citizen. You can live in
anyway. You live in Hawaii anyway.
You want people shovel in the net,
they fucking driveway.
It seems like madness to me,
kind of madness, but there's a certain
type of person that grows up around snow.
That's a hard year person.
I understand like Canadians
where they're like, ah,
I like to hunt and this and I
like to cut down trees and shit.
You know what I mean? I'm Sarah.
Yeah, yeah. I liked the top.
I'm going to put a tap in that tree over
there, get syrup out of it. I'm like,
all right, enjoy yourself, but I
don't understand like if you just,
if you live in the city,
let's say if you have an apartment
in the middle of one of these cities,
if you want to live in a big house
in the hills and be like, Eh,
I've brought you some elk. Right.
That's what I'm talking about. Yeah,
I understand that. But why?
Why do I live in New York City?
And I also don't understand why.
Let's say you have a shitty job.
Like you're the guy in a
booth that cuts keys, right?
And you'd fix heels and shoes.
I've never understood why those two
occupations are bound together. Together.
Yeah. It's always the shoe hit
fixing guy. Also, we'll cut keys.
I don't know if that's true. That
is, you know what I'm saying, man,
the mailbox, I, I, there's a like a ups
place that I sent him packages out of.
They also make keys.
Yeah. Keys, keys of attached to other
occupations. He catches them. A keystone
war. You got to have a case store,
you've got to go.
I make keys and donuts.
I never knew that the shoe dog shoe guy
is inherently mixed in with the key guy.
I understand the key guy when he's,
when he's hanging out with the guy,
put batteries in watches. Look
it. That's it. That's enough.
This is the sign for sale on Ebay.
It's fork.
He keeps getting that and
ship it to Jim Jefferies
cake cutting. That's the thing.
Pop. Please purchase that.
It's 29 99 first that I would
ship to. Oh, I'll have that.
I'll put that in my gymnasium. Um,
so, so they have those it. Okay.
Now if you do that
job and you're doing,
you fix fixer heal for five,
$10 and you do a key for $3 and you
sit in your booth Keon and chewing.
Well,
I do that in Manhattan.
Why don't you become the guy does
that in like Kansas, Manhattan?
No,
but you can live anywhere.
You're not making a lot of money
with that key business. Enough.
Pile up your cash, the rent in
every place. Get a new house there.
Yeah,
but it's a big investment to move.
See the big problem with moving is you
need three months where the rent they
need first, last and security.
That's a lot of fucking money. Sure.
You also need the moving truck.
You also need the time.
I could just give away all my shit.
I moved to England Guy Wellman, Shit.
I moved over here to America.
Gave away fucking everything.
Yeah, but you're a successful
comic. There's a difference.
You make a good living every week.
That stuff that you need to do your
job as minimizing. What do you need?
You need a notebook. When I
moved to Britain, I was flattered
broke and then when I moved over
here I actually was getting,
I was getting sued by paramount when
I moved over here and they basically
cleaned up my bank account as well.
Why were you getting sued?
I had a told them about stole Davy d
deal with paramount DVDs. You, UK.
I can speak about this now
because it's been so long.
I think I've the statue of whatever
it might be done. I don't give a fuck.
So I had,
I had this
DVD deal,
uh,
and I might one that was never meant to
have gone into the shops that I said I
can, I'm just going to make
one to sell after gigs.
So it was done really on the
cheap and it's called contraband,
which is sort of a cool name
for it because it wasn't
in shops and all that type
of stuff.
Right.
And what happened was I,
after I made that,
I just started to get popular in the UK
and they released this into the shops.
I already wasn't happy with them
cause it was a really shitty product,
really bicycling crap product.
Anyway, I come over here,
so I got that DVD in the shops over there.
I'm doing very well in Britain,
the well the end of a festival and stuff.
And I had a profile now I came over here,
I got my HBO special and I went back on,
couldn't use everyone.
I got an HBO special, I'm going
to make it in America now as well.
And The lady that was the executive,
it was like talking to a fucking child.
It was, she was like, but you've
still got a three deal with us.
And I'm there going, yeah,
but let me do this one.
Then we'll then we'll start
selling product in America.
I'll do the next three with you. You've
already got me for a cheap, right.
Let me do this one in America.
The raise my price. And she goes,
but you can't do that.
You your deals with us as our weight.
I'm doing the HBO special.
Sumi and so they, they,
they sued me for the advanced money
they gave me for the four. And then, um,
I see
Vance give you, well you don't have
to tell you, but 90,000 pounds.
And so you had to give him back.
Yeah. Which is like, which is like
150,000 American who was, you know,
a lot of money,
you know.
And I had to give him back that plus
plus money that I want to be less than
that. Anyway, I had to give them that
plus money that they'd spent on me.
So it was like another 20,000
pounds, whatever. And so I
said, all right for that,
I said,
you have to take contraband off the
shelves because I never liked that one.
So I got that DVD pulled from the shops
and I did a lot of jokes off that one.
We were in my HBO special as well,
but um, I got out of that deal.
Best thing I ever did because I've now
had three more deals since then to do
DVDs afterwards. It was the best thing
ever getting sued by those people.
But at the time I had that much money
minus 10 grand in my bank account and was
like,
and I felt like I was the richest guy
in the world are like a hundred thousand
pounds in my bank and I felt like I'm
sitting pretty and then I'm going to move
to America. And then I was fucking broke
man. They took it all the bastards.
Well, it sounds like they were
right. You had a deal. Oh No.
Unfortunately fundamentally
they were right,
but they could have made a lot more money
out of me if they just let me out to
do this one special.
But they wouldn't trust you to do that
because if you went and did that, you,
you see they're not making any money
off that HBO thing. The only way to get,
but I would have gotten alcoholic
cost for fully functional.
The one I'm about to record. Yeah,
but they would've never, how do we,
they know even you would stay alive.
They give you this HBO special,
you get hit by a meteor.
You know?
All I know is there was one of the
executives that were working for paramount
who agreed with me and
one of them who didn't.
And those two executives
were fine. I think one of the
execs actually left. Yeah.
Went to a different guy.
I went to work with Sony or something
because he was like, I can't fucking,
this was the stupid cause
I want to be a way to work.
I was the first British spies comic in,
I
can't even think of another one,
but let's say in a very long time to get
a major break in America to get an HBO
special or Showtime Special In America.
They had like,
like I'm sure Billy Connolly's
probably done one. Yeah,
Eddie's odds always produced
his own type of stuff.
But I was the first British guy to British
base guy to have that sort of thing
and there was no way I wasn't
going to fucking do it. Of course.
So I just opted out of my contract
and got sued. I don't, you know,
I'm not angry about, to this day I
feel like it worked out better for me.
But at the time it was like
someone punched me in the guts.
When you give over there all that money
still though, you loot, you
getting rid of all your stuff,
you're still a successful
comics. Oh No, no, no, no. It's
still, I still being hired
for the HBO shows. I had money
coming in. No, it wasn't.
It wasn't super difficult. Yeah. So,
but I'm saying this a lot harder
for a guy who was making keys. Yay.
Kt Slash v Guy.
If you really stop it,
think about a guy who has like a real
low paying job and the idea of saving
money and the idea of
figuring out saving money.
I was reading about this general, the,
he heard this case about this general to,
he got sued for sexual harassment
or for sexual misconduct.
Adultery apparently is
illegal in the armed forces.
That's how they got Patraeus betray us.
Got kicked out because of adultery,
which is pretty fucking unbelievable when
you think about you're allowed to kill
people, but you're not allowed to
fuck someone other than your wife.
Like they'll kick you out of the army
for that. Like okay. A little preachy,
but yeah,
but they talked about how much this guy,
how much he was making and you find
out how much like a general mix,
like they were talking about,
it was $4,000 a month or $5,000
a month for four months. They,
they took his money away.
Like he didn't get paid for four
months while this trial was going on.
I always find it amazing when you
find out how much the president, yeah,
like quarter of a million.
Yeah. Yeah. It's not,
well I think it's a
little more than that now.
I think it's like a half a mil for, for
the president. But I noticed that you,
I know that they earn less than the stage
hands. That kind of, Gee, Whoa, Whoa,
are you serious? [inaudible] kind
of. You hold the stage hands.
It kind of the whole union bites and you
can pass the job onto your children and
two thirds of the stage hands,
it kind of you hold, it's like a,
it's like a fact that they always
giving pop quizzes earn more than the
president.
Whoa.
In 2001 the president earned $400,000
along with $50,000 annual expense account,
$100,000 non taxable travel account.
Now how much is it today?
In 2014 today it's still 400 grand.
IPAD plus monster beats a trial account.
You always get an upgrade on Delta,
the total salaries,
five 50
per year with a an entertainment stipend.
He has a to $20,000 entertainment stipend.
That means he gets to have z come over
and singing a song in one he likes.
I don't think that's what it is. I think
it means like for his entertainment,
like money,
he spends things on to $20,000 a year,
which I guess over the
course of three days, 50,
well it's probably dinner
and stuff like that.
That's it. Probably what,
he didn't pay for anything.
I thought he just had a corporate card
where he could buy anything and it was on
us,
you know?
Well he has an expense account.
There's an annual expense can,
but it doesn't say how much it
is. Uh, but it says that in 1969,
Nixon made $200,000,
which is over a million
today in today's dollars.
So no per year. That's what his, his uh,
his salary was next and might
have given himself a raise there.
Yeah, he was a crook ahead. Said he
wasn't, oh, he was definitely a crook.
He's a piece of shit,
but everybody was okay.
Piece of shit back then. He was just
one of the first guys that get caught,
you know, there was a, a
whole series pieces of shits.
What is this as the interview
that Jimmy Carter did,
saying that he doesn't use a email to
talk or anything like that cause he thinks
the NSA spying on him. So you
only use this postal mail. Wow.
Now that he told them that they're
going to intercept is post a message.
Of course.
This is an ex president, right? Of course.
He doesn't even know how to use
a computer. That's being honest.
He probably knows how to use a
computer. He's pretty smart guy. Yeah,
peanut. Yeah. At a certain point
in time, I think you kind of,
everybody who's paying attention knows
how to use a computer in this day and age.
I'm the worst at it, but I can still a
mile and then you're better than dom.
Even Herrera should get together to
decide who is the worst because I say dumb
fucking beats you hands down.
Oh I can.
I can use Netflix and a mile and I can
look at things and update my web pages
and stuff. That's all I can do. But I was
the worst for years and years and years.
And then I always used to look at
like kids with computers and things.
Look at these fucking pretentious co
parents giving that kid an iPad when I
didn't have an Ipad,
you know what I mean?
And now I just gave my son
who's 16 months I go, I got it,
I got a new iPad and I gave him my
old one. They love him, I love him.
But also it's like you have to,
the world is now computers,
so the sooner he gets his hand on a
computer and his fiddling with a computer,
the better. Well, it's also,
there's connections that are made.
There's a bunch of games that kids can
play on iPads that are actually good for
your brain. They're making connections.
They figured out how to do puzzles.
They figured out how to
count things. There's like a
series of educational games.
The kids fucking love.
My three year old's steals my phone.
Every time I leave it down,
she'll open it and start going.
She knows how to open my phone.
She's fucking three.
She swipes it and enters in the code.
She knows what my code is,
goes right to the APP.
She wants and starts playing these games
and a lot of them are fucking really,
they're really good for your little brain.
Well,
my son's favorite game is a
cat that repeats what he says.
Well,
there's fun ones to my three year old
likes to do one where she gives a Manny
Petty's to dogs.
Yeah. There's a lot of
dressing. Things are like,
like this one the like,
like my son just looks at
and goes [inaudible] the
thing goes back at him and he
thinks that he laughs.
This is, it's, it's weird.
As a comedian and someone who is being
terrible at sports her entire life,
I see a lot of people with
dad's when they're like,
look, you just threw the bowl.
You just threw the bowl. I
literally with my son Go. He knows.
That's funny, right? Like I was,
I was proud in the same way that a
sporty dad who sees his son kick a goal.
I was proud. I saw my son,
he lifted up one ass cheek,
he farted and then he laughed
and I was like, he's developing. He knows
what's good and he knows the good bits.
My three year old runs
over her butt cheeks
and farts in my face right in my face.
Raw naked ass right out of the tub,
runs over.
Ben's over front of me and far it's in
my face and then fucking cries laughing.
She thinks it's the funniest thing.
Is Paul Funny? She Get mad? No,
I think it's hilarious. How did you
get mad? I did something. Shoot,
I didn't talk with my son that
I think may be illegal. Right.
You know when you do something you're
like, oh I might have committed a crime.
What'd you do? Well, I,
I'm in the shower as I do every morning
and he always comes up when he hears me
in the shower cause he wakes up about an
hour and a half before I do because he
wakes up early and he's,
mom takes care of him in the morning
and I'm having to shout and he comes up
when he hears that I'm awake and he
starts bashing on the glass door.
And what I do is because I'm
a, you know, adorable guy,
I always like paint a little like in
the condensation I drove a little tie on
him or give him a voice
bubble and then say,
Oh I love dad or something like that.
I do this a little game and
he laughs and uh, anyway,
so I stepped back and I got good morning
Hank and he slapped my cock and he ran
off.
Why is that illegal child
touching your cock right now?
I know like I didn't
ask him to touch my car,
but also is it illegal because I laughed
and then told you like point
of my Dick and laugh. Yeah.
Three year olds like penis.
She thinks it's hilarious though.
Penises, IRA, humorous. Sure.
Vaginas are humorous too.
Both of them. My, my,
my son now is at the stage
where loves holding east cock.
Just haul pinches it at the end cause
it's only [inaudible]. I don't know.
I haven't got, I haven't got a lot
of baby Cox to reference it against.
I think my son has a small car,
but it's,
I think it grows or right. I think
he has a nice direction, but I don't,
I think he has a very,
doesn't erections at 16 months.
I have erections from day one. Wow. Like
sometimes you wake him up in the morning,
would take his nappy off
because he's got a shit.
In the end it will be a shit covered
direction. Oh, that's a weird connection.
And a good name for a band.
It's probably already taken because
probably a website, but it's, uh, it's,
it is.
Yeah.
He gets like a little tiny woody and I
always think what is going on in his head
where he is wanted or needed an erection.
What was the dream that he had last night?
Oh,
I know the dreams that I'm having
when I wake up with an erection.
What are the ones that are
hit like is that, you know,
that cat saying suggestive
things off the IPAD? What is,
it's probably just blood in his deck.
It's probably just blood his dick or
it's longing for something that he,
you know,
I don't know.
You ever get boners when you
drive in for no apparent reason.
You're not even horny. I have, yes I
have. Those are weird. Those are boners.
Sometimes you got to have sex and you
got to fucking work at a bit to get it
going.
And then like other times you ever done
that one where you masturbate in the car
while you're driving, you get it right
because you've been stuck in traffic.
And then I W I was alright
with it in Britain,
but too many people in this
town drive SUV. Oh, I drive,
I drive a common challenge
or I'm lower down. Oh,
I get seen by a lot of people got to get
the windows or I could just stop waking
in my car or just get one of those things
women use when they breastfeed in public
and just jerk off onto that. Yeah,
get a quilt.
Yeah,
I found out the best thing to do is to
plug my phone into the iPod connection
and then play porn in it.
Cause then I'll get with subwoofer and
everything surround sound port in my car.
That's a good move.
So do you like hold it with one hand and
steer with like the last time? I know,
I know me,
you have to be in traffic so I'm not
doing that much steer and beating off in
your car.
Since I've lived in La last five years,
I know of three times this has happened.
It's not like I'm not going to do it.
Like right now, this is a hobby. This
is like I've, I've just been somewhere,
there's some girls got me going.
I mean a bit of a frenzy or I've
just had a fight with my girlfriend.
I'm in a bit of a bad mood. I
need to cheer myself up. Really,
I only beat off once in my car ever,
and it was when I was driving limos.
I was driving home from a Gig. Uh, I had
to drop some lady off in New Hampshire,
drive way the fuck up in New Hampshire.
It's a long ride back,
like an hour and a half back.
I got boards I'd beat off and I
remember the fucking massive feeling of
disappointment in myself that I jerked
off because I'm jerking off underneath my
shirt. As soon as I came,
I was like, God damn it.
This is going to be a thing I do all
the time now. And I never did it again.
I was shocked, but it never came
up. I never wanted to do it again,
but I'm shocked because I figured I'm
such a fucking idiot once I do something
embarrassing like that, I'm like,
well, this is something I do now.
This is not going to be,
I'm not going to like
I remember I remember once having sex
with a go and she was just yelling at,
fuck me Daddy. Fuck me. Right.
And I kind of went, hey,
what are you calling
me that like this fort?
And then I slightly enjoy
it as saying it and I don't,
I don't need that to be a thing.
Yeah,
don't make that a thing for
me because then I'm fucked up,
but I've got to ask other people to
do it and then we're in a real fucking
predicament.
When I was in Boston, I was, I used to
bang this really crazy Portuguese chick.
She used to call her pussy cunt.
It was the first girl I'd ever,
ever heard say that. She's like,
fuck that cunt. Fuck that bitch.
She was like angry about it and I was
like, I hope I don't start liking this.
That's going to be hard to get someone
else to agree to write a lot of gals.
Yeah.
It's hard when you've got a thing and
you've got to ask you go to do that thing.
I, I, for a while there, I loved choking
girls while I was fucking him for awhile.
I'm not as Chunky as I used to be,
but I used to be. I used to be.
I used to be very fucking hand around
the nic pin you down while I was fucking
you. Right. And some girls
and I was dying. He had got
off on doing that. Right.
And that was, that's what got me
into it was this is how I made this.
And then you meet the goals.
We don't want you to do that.
But then I met one girl who I was
choking her and then, uh, you know,
I'm not checking the whole time.
Right.
And then I've stopped and she's
thought of as thought, oh,
this is what we're doing, is it, she
starts choking me and I'm like 30 that,
that feels horrible.
I don't know how bad it feels for you
women, but it really hurts my mail neck.
The choking thing is,
it's weird.
It's just like one of those other things
where some people love it and some
people hate it and you never fucking
know until it comes up. You know,
you could date a girl and I have no idea.
She likes to be choked.
Like the first girl I ever dated
that lock to be choked was so girly.
She was like, so like you would
never, she was, it wasn't loud.
She always wore dresses.
She Wa she wasn't like
boisterous or you know,
slotting in ever slutty. Just a
regular girl and she fucking loved it.
She asked me to choke her and there was,
I was like, what do you mean choke you?
Like how, how do you
mean choke you? She goes,
just grabbed my neck while you're
fucking man. I'm like, okay, hard.
Do you want me to hurt you?
Like what's going on here? Like,
and then if you thought about doing it
to another girl, they would freak out.
Like it's weird what like one person,
what's their big turn on?
And another person,
it's a southern of know is bad when you,
when you bring the choke into a go,
he doesn't want it. It's
always bad. I'm like, ah.
I was with the girl that I had an iron
deficiency and every time she would want
me to choke her the next day she would
just have like these horrible bruises
around her neck and she just would have
to like where like turtle necks and
stuff. But it looked like if I ever
got in trouble, oh, I'm fucked.
Diagnoses and anemic, which
really, yeah. Which isn't pleasant.
Do you eat a lot of red meat? I
do. Yeah. I'm basically saying,
did you ever take iron supplements?
I'm going to stop on iron supplements.
I've never tell him. Well, I need, I think
a dog talking. I was like three days ago,
I'm actually going to the doctor again,
30 minutes for the second check on this.
You know, you, uh, you still
smoke cigarettes. I'd probably
has a factor in too. Yep.
No doubt. Cigarettes. Uh, I think,
I think that's one of the scent.
Is that what is anemic?
Yeah,
just you don't have low
hemoglobin in your blood.
They did a blood test. It's the
hemoglobin Globin globin hemoglobin.
Hemoglobin oxygen. Yeah.
I'm not hugely anemic. Yeah.
There's a link and I'm a little bit,
uh, yeah, a little bit tinny me.
There's a pub med study on it.
The effects of cigarette smoking on
hemoglobin levels and a anemia screening.
Yeah. I, uh,
it seems to cause a generalized upward
shift of the hemoglobin distribution
curve,
which reduces the utility of the
hemoglobin level to detect anemia.
So it, your body doesn't detect anemia,
so it doesn't compensate as much.
Also, I'm a, I'm, I'm a super pale guy.
Uh,
and that's when you say super pile
people is often that they've been naming,
I think I'm anemic. Oh yeah, you got
it. He's always fucking cigarettes, man.
He's done this, that exist. I was
just born like, I'm pile for a pile.
We're just pie.
He's like,
one of the things I hate about being
pale is it's seems like one of the few
things in society about why of human
being looks that people in society could
just pass fucking judgment with and
like not act like they're being cuts.
Yeah. They can make fun
of you. Yeah. Right.
If you see someone with a big nose and you
go, fuck, you got a big nose. People go,
Whoa, he's up with, yeah. But you go,
I'll have all that people who act as
on my fucking show, who I'm employing,
who want to be in more fucking episodes.
Go Fuck your pile man.
Fuck you. That's fine. You get
offended by that. For Real. I know.
I just find a reason to say,
I don't know.
I do get offended by it in the sense
that it doesn't bother me personally,
that I'm pale. It bothers me when people
bring it up. I don't mind looking power.
I even dislike,
I did a photo shoot once for some head
shots and the lady fucking put bronzer or
I mean that whole photo shoots ruined
because I'd look to Brown and it doesn't
suit me. You can't let them fuck with
you with the makeup and tanning. Tanning.
Yeah. That's what you to do. I
take a selfie in a tanning booth.
Gay Bay self. We have a
book. It's not the gas.
You don't have a copy in your
mouth or your outside to my hand.
I try to,
uh,
I tried my whole life to sound bake and
the Tan and to get doc all through high
school when it did affect me,
when I did not like the way
I looked or it wasn't at all.
It wasn't an ease with the way I look.
Oh I see.
So there's a residual thing when someone's
making fun of you saying you're pale.
It used to be a thing used to come he
Casper at school and stuff like that and
it's not about black people
like no damn you're dark.
Like you know a guy really the whole
world wants to be like a coffee color.
Right.
Because all of us white people are trying
to like get darker and then the really
black people now it's very
common to bleach their skin.
That bleach it down a bit. They don't
want to be super black is a really, yeah,
there was a thing,
I was watching it on something I chose
this lady get don't bleach and a kids
cause she didn't want them to be super,
super black.
They want to all be Beyonce Brown.
Beyonce brown I think
is the term that's a,
that's a type of paint that you get done
at home depot. I was some Beyonce Brown.
Um,
it's like they want to be Beyonce,
sort of that Whitney Houston sort of
color and white people want to be dark it
and we all want to meet in this one.
Sort of middle range
Mexican. Yeah, there's a,
there's a nutritional supplement that
allows people to bleach their skin.
It's something that's been really
popular in the Philippines.
Um, fuck is the stuff
called. There's a, there's,
there's an actual like nutritional
supplements that people take and they
injected apparently,
and it's gained popular in the
Philippines for some strange reason.
Well,
you even look like the movie stars are
always sort of like a more milky black.
And then when you have like a girl
who was that girl out of Africa,
I think she's out of Africa.
She was British or something out of 12
years of his life. I didn't see that. Um,
she got nominated for the Oscar alert
dog odds. Great. Yeah. And she was,
she was amazing in it,
but now they would,
they were talking about
like how liberating or how
good it was to see an actual
black woman portrayed like you
know, like she, she had afro,
he taught the Hay like shut down.
She wasn't trying to look like a watch
chick or something. You know what I mean?
The fashion people were going nuts.
We really liked this.
Now I think where I lead Wa
maybe see if I was black,
I don't understand women
who, whose, who did the,
if I was playing I'd be Afro all day. I
would be like Jackson five top. I know.
I always,
whenever you see a chick with that Hairdo,
it's always like fucking looking at fucks.
See Chick.
It's always a big turn from a turn on
for me. I love a chick with an Afro.
It was big in the 70s and she's town
that foxy brown had it, right? Yeah.
When you see like the chickies like I'm
a member of the Black Panthers and they
got the big fucking Afro, you're
like, fuck it. Take me down.
The white man choke me. Glutathione
is it? That's, I couldn't remember it.
[inaudible] they uh,
they take a injections of this
shit or they rub it on her skin.
I don't know what the fuck
they're doing, but uh, maybe both.
But gludethyon apparently makes
your skin lighten. That's it.
That's how you want to look at that
for there. That's on her asshole too.
Yeah. You should have a big hairy
thing between the legs and a hairy
[inaudible] is the
worst thing in the world
are really used to be,
didn't used to be a problem at all.
Yeah. But I, there was
a girl, there was a guy,
fuck did our island who was one of the
best looking girls I ever fucking light
our eyes on.
And she was at a Gig and I was like single
and young in my twenties and I might
like,
I'm going to get that girl right.
And I was gigging it on for three days
and I romance this girl from the moment I
met her.
I took her out to lunch the next day and
then dinner and the thing and took her
to another show. Invited a
friend. I worked there. Right.
And it's very hard to
fucking Irish chicken.
This chick was about 19 it's hard to
fucking Irish chick. Yeah, they've got it.
They've all gone to Catholic schools.
They all have this cloud
of sex is evil over them.
They didn't have playboy
until the mid 1990s right.
It's a pretty repressed old
sexual society, the island.
Anyway, so I fucking got this
girl, she's a little bit like,
she wasn't up for it,
but I convinced her and said,
I'm going to come over to London and
hang out with me. And I was like,
this is like my girlfriend now on
that. And then it was like, what?
What was his like 2004 and like a
fucking a full length wild Bush.
And I had grown up in this era of
not really seeing it. I was just,
I almost couldn't find, I did fuck it,
but I almost couldn't. It was so horrific.
I still have flashbacks of it right
now as I'm saying, and I can see it.
It was menacing.
Here's the total complete opposite.
When I was in high school,
I was dating this girl dating,
like, you know, we would date,
we'd go on and off and you
know, it didn't, you know,
in the on and off she was banging
this other guy who told her,
told her to shave her pussy.
So she came over my house and,
uh, we're about to get it. And she's
like, I can't, I can't take my pants off.
And I go, why she, cause you're gonna
think I'm a whore. And I go, why?
Why am I going to think you're
a whore? Like she goes, cause
whatever the guy's name is,
he talks to me to shape my pussy
and I'm so embarrassed. I'm like,
I don't give a fuck. Like what do I
care, you know, east it and freaked out.
Well, I didn't care. No,
not at all. I was, but,
but she was scared that I was going
to see her with a shave pussy.
The complete opposite. It's the
only way to go. But this is like,
you know,
1980 whatever the hell it was.
I always thought if I got a weird,
when there's,
there's always women that you know
have a Harry Bush when they're having a
conversation with you and you're like,
why would men want to have
sex with like a shave pussy?
Like I must be like having sex
with like a child and you're like,
that is the weakest argument.
You could fucking and then what then
then you should only kiss men was beads.
If you kiss him, man, he shaved his face
when he kissing. A young boy is straight.
You fucking pedophile go out with
a fucking Muslim comp with a beard.
Where are your happiest,
right?
It's actually,
did you know that pet harassed is someone
who actually has sex with children on
a rough pedophile, better
rast, right? Pet a raft.
That's a good spot for
a pedophile pedophile.
Someone who's attracted Peder rast is
someone who has sex with them but not
attracted. Yeah, they just
do it because it's fun.
That's a very good analogy though.
The beard analogy and the Bush analogy.
Some people just don't want to do
anything that they don't want to do.
Anything that like is society standard,
like a woman doesn't want to have to
agree like why should I shave my pussy?
Why should I have to like you someone
when they're like that? Like what?
Because it's in porn. Is that what it is?
Cause that's what it is. It's it's, yeah,
and Monterey Bay.
It might be because in porn,
but it's also because once a man's
used one of those shaving one's,
it's a lot more enjoyable than
the coarseness of the, well,
I've remember fucking hairy pussies and
having my cock old beaten up like it's
been fucking rip through a Brillo right
pad.
The last one I had,
which is a way back in the 90s the
last girl, the crazy wild Bush.
It's like my Dick. I don't
Rub Bra. It was horrible.
It was like fucking a Brillo pad.
It's,
it shouldn't be.
It shouldn't be a fucking
like Dow and I show,
I'm sure he could explain it while we
have Harry nuts and bolts and stuff,
but pbk should die out.
They reckon crabs is dying out because
of the shaving pussy that it's on the
decline because it can't
be passed so easily.
But you know it's on the rise
and hipster beards. Crabs.
That's where they live now. They just
jump from one Pabst Blue Ribbon Kansas.
Isn't that true? No, that would
be cool because it's Christ.
I hate out. Hipsters now call themselves
nerds. They do. Yeah. It's, well,
it's like even like case I'm doing,
I got nothing.
I'm doing the notice podcast sooner. I
these guys, Chris Hardwick's a nice bloke.
He's a nice guy. Not a nerd. No.
He's a handsome guy with a very handsome
guy with like a model girlfriend.
Not being interested in star wars
does not make you a fucking nerd.
Heavy hobbies isn't what a nerd is.
Symmetrical face.
You know what a nerd is?
A nerd is a person who can't hold down
a conversation and can't look a woman in
the eye. That's a fucking nerd, man.
Your Napoleon dynamite. The
Polian darn amount, isn't it?
Even the guys off of, uh, the
Big Bang theory, they illness,
but these now these like girls going,
girls wearing tee shirts going,
I heart nerds. Really, really a guy
with a fucking club foot and, and, and,
and flaky skin around his
face. Is this, are you hot?
Does it guy with food stuck in
his braces? Patchouli, yeah. Who,
who is a little bit autistic and
that's why he's good at school,
but not at everything else. Yeah. You like
that? Yeah. That's, that's what you like.
How dare you? No, you, you like,
you like wearing a fucking backpack that
looks like Elmo. That's what you enjoy,
darling. You're like, Hello Kitty
stickers on your iPhone. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. All right. And then like
you'll see like a girl would be like,
I'm a nerd and she's wearing perfect
pigtails and classes and I'm like,
you're a fucking fuck machine.
You're, you're a com depository.
That's hardly a nerd.
I remember not wanting to fuck
nerds because they were nerds.
Why all of a sudden as the nerd
culture becomes so fuckable well,
I think people are just always trying
to be a part of a fucking group,
whether it's be hipsters, be nerds, be
whatever they used the learner in school.
I didn't have many friends,
but I wouldn't classify myself as a nurse.
How can be now friends.
I had problems making friends
and the main problem I have now,
um, that I, I, when I look back
on it, I wasn't good at sport.
I'm a bit of a Dick as well as
a little bit,
probably two, probably talked a little
bit too much when I should have shut up.
You know,
my have been irritating.
But I think my main problem was because
I found it very easy to make friends
after school.
Once I got out of school,
I found it very easy to
make friends in university.
I made friends very easily and uh, my
mother was a school teacher at my school.
Oh, fucking Christ. Not
just any school teacher,
the 300 pounds skilled teacher that
yelled at everybody that walked around and
she got it at school and at home. Oh my
God. Cool. Must have been fucking torture.
Go is not a fun time. Oh my God. I
remember when I went to university,
like actually enjoying this whole,
wow, we're all these fucking, yeah,
and like girls liking me
and shit. I'm like, ah,
this is what it's like when your mother
isn't within five feet of you all the
time. Oh yeah. That's a big difference
though. That's a terrible situation.
You got your mother who's telling her
older brother to kick your fucking ass and
then you get to school and she's
the one that yells at everybody.
All your friends know that
your mom is the conti teacher
that yells at her,
right?
Yeah. So none of your friends. I
had a couple of friends at school,
but they never wanted to come over
the hat.
You know what I mean?
Like it was a very hard sell.
What are you coming to
my house that's not,
let's just go to the woods.
Let's go hang out with the wallaby's
that's going out in the bush.
I have a foot fetish. Yeah, no,
I just wondering,
I just wondering if you had any like
mom type sexual mom's a foot, foot,
foot fetish. People have mom.
Yeah, cause they're, yeah,
cause as a young kid you always see
your mom, you see your mom's feet. Yeah.
But I disliked my bullet. Yeah, I
didn't, that's why I say if he had some,
all right. I uh, she, she's all
right. She's all right now. You,
I find I get a lot more,
I liked my mother more now that I've had
a child because she has proven herself
to be a good grandmother.
But uh,
but she was fucking hard work,
man. I used to say too, I said,
why did you make me go to the same
school that you are teaching it?
It was noise nearby school. And she
goes, well I was there first. I'm like,
are you competing with your fucking kids?
Go teach at the school.
Over the road there's,
there was,
there was an all girls
school just down the street.
I don't care if you teach with it a
school within a half a mile of where I am.
Well, I was there for,
I was at first place.
She just liked to keep
it honest constantly.
It's very dominating childhood.
Very good.
Look how you turned out you
flung the other way. That's
how it works. Yeah. I mean,
what we were talking about about you
having a hard time shutting up in school
and being a bit of a Dick. All those
things are perfect for being a comedian,
the comedian, a bit of a Dick
and talks a little too much.
That's the guy who's going to say
the funny shit first. Yeah, right.
I,
you know what's weird now is I go back
to Sydney and all the guys I went to
school with who I, they probably
didn't think they were bullying me,
but who I felt bullied by
for whatever reason. Um,
they all come as a group to
my shows and they're like,
come and meet me backstage and they say,
oh, happy that I got to hold no grudges.
They're good guys.
You know what I mean?
But they weren't my mindset
school and I remember them.
I think kids get bullied at school for the
same reason. Survival. Yeah. Will they?
It's, it's, it's a natural instinct
and they get shitty parenting.
I think that's a lot of where it
comes from. They get bullied at home.
It becomes a natural part of how you
behave. You get bullied by your brothers,
get bullied by your dad,
get bullied by your uncles who,
and then the first opportunity you
get to shit on somebody you do.
It's a lot of it is kids that grow up
associating other people with competition
and abuse and you know,
they just associated in a negative way.
It was a,
the bit I found hardest about the
whole thing was fuck the guards.
I just want to chicks to log me.
Well that's why you got into comedy,
right?
Yeah.
Well I got into company growth,
so I actually did pretty good with girls
in high school. I look back on it now.
Photos of me, 1670 I was a good looking
kid. I didn't think it at the time,
but I look back on it
like I wasn't bad looking at that age.
I did
good in high school,
but then after high school I went
through a fucking terrible drought.
That didn't,
didn't go away until I became a comic.
Oh No, I did. I bet she is for high
school and university. Really? But I,
I was getting it attract
the never go at my school.
It was always I had to
go see other schools,
find out where their parties
were happening to get light.
Oh, so girls that knew you,
it was a problem. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. If you'd spent, if you spent
more than 10 minutes with me,
you were fucking with me.
But if I could,
if I could meet you at a party where the
music was too loud that I couldn't bore
you with conversation, there was a
good chance that I have sex with you.
I didn't get laid at all in college and
the reason being is I took a year off
after high school and
then went to Umass Boston,
which was like a commuting high school.
It was not a high school where you are
not a college rather community college.
It wasn't a college where you a was
to go and stay there, you would,
you would live somewhere else,
you know,
and then you would go and
take your classes there.
So everybody was like working
and I was a loser, you know,
I didn't have anything going on. I was,
I was a martial arts champion, but I was,
I was poor and I was teaching
martial arts and I was trying,
the only reason why I was
going to school at all, well,
so that people didn't
think I was an idiot.
I studied musical theater. Did you? Yeah.
So you've got to bang actresses.
It was the best. It was.
It was like they only took 20
kids a year into the course.
3000 people auditioned. Whoa. Right.
It was like a very prestigious thing.
It was the same course of Hugh Jackman
did and there was an acting paper.
I couldn't, not good enough. So
I got, I knew I could sing a bit.
So I got in the musical theater thing
and I could back in the day. Yeah.
You sing now. No soundtrack
to legit. I'll tell you.
I'll tell you something
about me. You might not know.
It's a little fact about me.
I Sang,
I sang twice in the Australian opera,
in the course as an employed opera
singer. Yeah. Wow. I was like,
what? Kinda like what I wasn't, I
wasn't. I've had, I've had vocal nodules.
I've had surgery and my voice, I can't,
it's over. I'm not making up though. I,
I sang in a child's Bruno's Romeo and
Juliet and Wagner as the flying Dutchman
as chorus vocal nodules, um,
pull ups on your vocal chords.
Basically calluses from smoking coke.
A yelling is mostly from yelling from
the bashing together. They get calluses.
So you can't actually get your vocal
cords close enough together to make high
sounds because there's always a gap
in them from these little things.
So it makes you a man, it's
like a noodles. A fucking
man is what it is. Yeah.
Well I guess,
yeah,
exactly.
It's like these,
these grisled comedians who have
yelled on stage all the time.
It's because they that just covered like,
you know,
what else is bad comedy like
Bobby slight and Paul up top.
I'm telling you that guy, his vocal
cords is just, just a nodular,
nodular. I'm telling you, he
might've had a vocal surgery
if I'm, I might be wrong, but I've,
I've heard of comedians
that have had that before.
It's more than why I had this before.
I was a Canadian to try
to save the singing curry.
So he had surgery on
the polyps. Yeah. Yeah.
So they shaved down the council couldn't,
couldn't talk for a,
couldn't talk for two minutes.
Oh my God. Two months. Yeah.
Just riding on a fucking pad. Oh, that
was when I, that was when I thought,
this job,
I'm going to get these back because I
partied too much and then I thought,
I've got no other skills. I got no
other skills in the fucking world.
And I decided I always
wanted to be a comedian,
but it wasn't a job that my parents
would never let me do or let you do that.
He said it wasn't,
my parents were happy with the musical
theater because they saw my mother could
brag and act like it was a bit more light.
He die then the whole thing.
But I decided I was going to be a comedian
in that two months where I couldn't
talk. Wow. And it was like a
secret that I had to myself. Like,
that's fucking awesome.
And I'd already,
I was like checking out what were
the open mics were in Howard.
I started watching a lot of standup
videos and, and that's what I did,
you know, living by myself, not
talking for a couple of months.
That's fucking awesome. And, uh,
what was I talking about before with the,
uh, the great thing about the cost day,
so 10 boys, 10, 10 girls. Uh,
and there was two, two years above us,
so it was three years. So there was,
it was like 90 people in the
whole sort of department half,
uh, 80% of the men would
guy right in the course.
Let's study musical theater. So we had
eight guy guys and to heterosexuals,
all the women were fucking hot as fuck.
We're like,
like been dancing since I was a kid and
just seeing in fucking they would just,
and we were all like 20.
It was the best thing ever.
I didn't even, I is the reasonable
looking fucking heterosexual guy.
It was fantastic.
Now one of the main girls
in the course was a go cold.
Uh,
Shantelle Barry and Chantel was going
was the one that we were all like,
she's going to be a star.
She was stunning. You can
look her up in the night.
She was fucking stunning. She could sing
better than everyone else. She could.
She was,
she had everything is go right.
And then they brought out
the first version of like
pop bottle or American idol
or whatever that it was done in Australia
first and was called miking the band
or whatever the show is actually
originated in New Zealand.
But then in Australia
they might just go bang,
called Bardo were all the people came in
and auditioned to be in his girl band.
And the goal that I was at university,
she went to this audition for this TV
show she got in the band but they played
it over weeks and weeks and weeks
and they'd cameras in the house.
And it was the first reality,
big reality show ever where
we were watching these
people just living in a house
and people couldn't fathom within,
there's no act as this is real.
It was like a very, there she
is there. Yeah. Anyway, so uh,
I used to stand behind her stretching
and dance class every and just fuck it.
Just all I wanted was to have sex with
this young lady never happened. Right.
So anyways,
so she gets in this band and
she stills the story guys.
She stills on a 10 or $20 out of one of
the other girls who were in the bands a
bag and she gets caught cause
it's fucking cameras everywhere.
So she's got this big opportunity.
Everyone else who was in this band has
gone on to big things like Sophie monk
who's the model out here dated Ryan
Secrets for while she was one of the other
girls in the band and now does big
modeling in his movies and Shit. Right?
So he shan't tell,
gets kicked out of the
fucking bank right over right.
So she moves over.
She's bad press in Australia.
They're all really slagging
her off and what type of stuff?
She was sort of a friend and she,
she moved over to La and I remember
like looking at a myspace page like wow,
she's made in la. She was backup singing
for Lionel Richie or something. Right?
Like got everything worked out for,
right.
Cut to first season of legit.
We need a girl in a sane that
he's just hot girl number two,
right. She comes into the audition. I
went, fucking hell. Shantelle Berry.
She didn't recognize me or remember
me at all. And I said, oh wait,
where's your accent from him? And then I
started saying the suburb she was from,
if I'm at this and you have
two older sisters. Yeah.
You look like someone who has two oldest,
cause I used to potty
at a house as this goes,
I got you got a butterfly
tattoo just above your ass.
Just stuff to, and she goes,
yeah. And I, when I went away,
went to university together.
Right. And then she went, oh did we find,
and then I went, oh I give her the pot,
right.
Because I'm a good guy.
The pot had like one line
and then she came on set.
And I think in that moment,
this is how much of an ocelot must be.
She remembered who I was from school
when she came on,
since he came on set, she was
like, cause Jim Jeffrey, I,
my real last name is Nugent.
I use my middle name as a
stage name because of Ted.
No, I just did. Jim Jefferies sounded
better than Jim Nugent. Jim Jeffrey,
you know what I mean? It was just, it
was a little tiny thing to alliteration,
you know, so she, I wasn't
going by my original name,
so she had no reason to her.
And then I sort of reminded and I said
how he used to come over and your mommy's
to make this type of food and blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah.
I think she was so pissed off
that I made it and she didn't.
But I had my own TV show that uh, she
went up to the producer and went, ah,
I've got food poisoning. I need to
go home and just walked off the set.
What didn't even do the job?
Maybe she's just kinda little squirt.
Maybe she had to leave.
Really didn't take the Gig man.
What makes you think that it's
because of that? I just think it's,
I just think people get fucking
jealous man. We all get jealous.
I think she just was like,
fuck this can cause I was
the guy at university that
you thought wouldn't make it
all the other gay guys at
abs or what type of stuff.
And I was like a bit of a doorway fucking
marshmallow looking kind of who could
sing a little bit. He couldn't dance at
all and was acting was pretty average.
They always kicked out like five
people a year from the course,
like you're not good enough.
I left after I got the nodules and I knew
I was going to get kicked out anyway.
That was already rot on the cods. I walked
before I, I jumped before I was pushed.
That competitive thing of show business
is one of the weirdest aspects of it.
Yeah.
Sometimes even in relationships.
I had a friend who got something in his
girlfriend started crying when he got
some part in some TV show
and his girlfriend started
crying because she was like,
well, something to happen for me.
Like that was her immediate reaction.
And I remember thinking,
wow,
I gotta get rid of that. But it's
something that's about to happen to you.
Yeah. That had very unattractive,
that competitive thing.
Yeah. I, you can't help it
a little bit with comedy.
It's very hard to never have it
with any other stope colleague.
There's always going to be one
where you go, that guy. But I, I,
I found out now and I think it's
easier because I got a bit of success,
but I don't give a shit what any,
I just worry about me.
I don't give a fuck if someone's going a
movie or something. I don't give a fuck.
I just worry about me. And
then you know, the good guys,
you know the bad guys and that's it.
But when in the early days it was more,
I got more jealous at how's
that going at that club?
I'm going to try and get
into that club forever.
That's just the frustration
of not having made it yet.
And then once you have
and you got some success,
it goes away and then you
can actually enjoy it.
Well,
I think there's successful people who
are still fucking don't want any other.
Well,
there's a lot of successful people also
that only work with terrible comedian so
that they shine.
Have you ever seen like a really good guy
who brings like the fucking worst guys
ever on the road to open forum,
torches the audience for a half an hour
with the worst fucking Shit standup ever?
Just so they can come in and clean
up the show and look like a hero.
And that's really what it is.
They don't want anybody to shine.
That's a very, we'd a
common, yeah, it's common,
but it's, I always sang,
I like, he's uh, uh,
chase the dream that the competition.
It's a good saying. You know what I mean?
Cause if you're worried about the
competition, you'll always feel,
it's like people who get angry at fucking
Aziz Ansari, like, who the fuck can,
you know what I mean? Who
gets angry with Daca? I,
there's plenty of comics who don't think
he deserves. What does that mean though?
What does deserve, these are
the, this is my thing. Well,
whether you like him or not,
you're not a little tiny Indian
bloke who's a little bit hip hop.
So at least the guys unique,
he's not stepping on your fucking toes.
I'm never admin another can't lock him.
In the comedy community,
it's that zero sum thing that people have.
This idea that there's
a finite amount of gigs,
there's a finite amount
of audience members.
And if Jim Jefferies becomes
big and that takes away from me.
I've had people accuse me of being
like a foreigner coming over,
taking American jobs. That's hilarious.
Who did that? Had a few comic.
Oh No,
they're not people you'd know.
Anyway
cares. Name them. So
we don't ever know him.
Sorry. There's a radio station in
tamper that got into me about that.
Oh my God, that's so sad. I said that
I'd come over and fucking America,
it might be famous and blah blah. I
should look. I give back to America, man.
I say my show employees over a hundred
people and I've written it. I produced,
this is a recent thing. Yeah. Yeah.
And I said my TV show our employees over
a hundred different people in different
jobs. Right. And then he went, we'll,
if you didn't do it then an American
would do it and you're like,
it doesn't matter mate. I did a
true, oh I did. It doesn't matter.
But that's not true.
That that idea is not true.
The idea that if you didn't make that
show, someone else would make that Shelby.
And now this show, it's
place, so something,
I don't know who the fuck
knows what it would be.
Might not employ as many people.
It might not be a drama.
It might be a reality show that
employs very few people works nonunion.
You know that, that, that
attitude is so stupid.
All right. It's all started. A
whole immigrant thing that you get,
and I got it in the UK as well,
is we're all fucking immigrants.
Exactly.
Everyone ready states is a
hundred percent immigrants. Yeah.
100% immigrants or the
children of immigrants. Yeah.
That's how this was made.
Unless you're native American
and they say 80% of all
businesses in America now, uh,
either from immigrants or the sons and
daughters, first generation immigrant,
even if you're on native American, that
means you came over on the Bering strait.
Your great, great, great, great
grandfather walked here from fucking Asia.
Is that why it happened? I didn't
even need, that's very fascinating.
And native American,
I mean less you're talking about native
Americans at were they have their DNA
combined.
Like Mexicans is a lot of native Americans
that had sex with Spaniards like way,
way, way, way back in
the day. But when you,
when they do the DNA
chart of native Americans,
one of the things they found
when they were researching,
there was a guy who was a
Mormon, a hardcore Mormon,
and he's a really rich guy.
And he wanted to prove that Joseph Joseph
Smith was correct and everything that
he said in the Bible was true and that
the native Americans were the lost tribe
of Israel. So we mapped out the,
the genome of the native Americans.
It turns out they're from Siberia.
So they came down,
they walked when it was a solid land map.
They've got sort of Siberia.
Is that near Mongolia?
No. Well, Siberia is Russia.
Russia's sort of near it in the fact
that the Mongols actually invaded, uh,
they in, they invaded a Russia
and some that go with g.
If you, I've traveled the fucking world
and I don't know anything. Well, it's saw
that's all in the same, I mean,
you wouldn't want to walk there,
but I mean it's all on the same land mass.
All snow. It's all suck.
Like very soft. Shoveling.
The fucking driveways get what? The
happiest Shit we're in the tennis, right?
Well I reckon the happiest place on earth,
Denmark or something and it's like
highest tax bracket and, and you know why?
It's because the most content people,
maybe not the happiest,
most content people in in Denmark
because it gets fucking docket three.
And that is,
you don't even dream about being
a famous movie star or a musician.
There's no entertainment
business that comes out of it.
You have to keep your dreams that
know I slow level in Denmark.
So you never get crushed by
the world. The world. Never.
You never have a girlfriend going,
when's it gonna Happen For me?
All you have is people sitting around
Denmark going, oh, well, you know,
on Saturday we're going to have a drink,
aren't we? So I'll see. I'll see. Hans,
that'll be fun.
That's as much as your dreams.
Get to Saturday having a beer
with your buddy. You know,
you never get ahead of yourself.
There's a Werner Herzog documentary on
Siberia called happy people life in the
taiga. It's about all these
people that live up there.
Virtually no mental illness, lot of
fucking really content happy people.
All they do is fish and trap and hunt.
That's all they do.
It's all they do.
They trade like skins and
meat and fish for you know,
fucking chainsaw blades.
Cause that's the thing is,
you know when you go fishing,
there's very few people that can
fuck you over in your day. It's true.
You go work in an office,
you're getting fucked over by
people who were smiling at you.
Well you're also dealing with unbelievably
unnatural behavior sitting in a box,
the same box every day,
eight hours a day plus and commuting
and all day you're sitting and you're
fucking, he. There's no
physical movement at all.
There's nothing explosive going on
with your body. No use of your senses.
No fight or flight.
So say that.
It's like the bullying thing that you see.
You see these people who were,
when you first walk into ca
where assistance and they
sat in the front thing and
I'd always have a jar of m and m's and
they'd be like, Hey Jim, great to see you.
Oh, here's some evidence.
Here's the water.
Like the happiest person in the world
I'm going to have in the world. Oh.
And then they'll have that con that sat
behind him that used to just call them a
piece of shit cause they got
their coffee order wrong. Right.
And then they'd go home and cry even
though they smiled to you because it was
part of their job.
And then the second I get to move into
that back a little room and they get a
person up there, they're fucking
telling that person there or can't,
they can't get coffee to save their life
within the circle of life. Never ends
that Kevin Spacey Movie. Uh, which one?
The Kevin Spacey movie where he's
like the worst fucking employee ever,
or the employer ever.
He's like an agent and he hires some
guy and they wind up kidnapping him.
What was that moving? Kevin's Beth
fucking shit. I can't remember that movie.
Kevin Spacey.
Agent movie.
Yeah,
he's a fucking car.
Please. I got to get gone. I got to get to
the doctor's guys. Oh, is that a problem?
No, we've done never problem
problems. Two and a half hours.
I just want to tell people what
this fucking movie has. God dammit,
uh,
horrible bosses.
That's not the movie.
That's another movie that he made that
was based around the original first movie.
Find it.
Find
a Chamie. Find it before
we wrap up. That's your
assignment. Funding neighbor. Uh,
that's not a sign that wasn't there movie
called Kangaroo Jack or something? You,
yeah.
Yeah.
There was definitely that kangaroo
jack to my girlfriend at the moment.
Can't leave the house because we lived
just Jamie said swimming with sharks.
That's exactly what it is. Yeah.
That's fucking great. That's a,
that's a great movie.
We see what kind of a terrible
environment that agent environment is.
It's the worst. Oh, that's the one where
he sweat. I've seen the speech out of it.
There's a torches.
This young kid that works for him.
I used to have a girl that I
dated that worked for an agent.
She'd wake up in the middle of
the night freaking out like that.
She forgot to do something in the
middle and he was brutal. He was just,
that's like every occupation must have
that where you wake up and they're like,
oh, I forgot to ah shit.
Yeah, but it's a 24 hour job.
What about like the bloke who,
who put bolts on engines for GM?
Well, there's obviously this inspectors
at handle that along with, yeah,
but it just takes a couple of people that
have a bad dice simultaneously. Yeah.
This girl though, uh, this,
this Gig of being an assistant to
an agent was literally all day.
Like he would call her up in the
middle of the night. I need eggs,
I don't have any eggs. Go get me
some eggs, bringing in my house.
Like he would have to, she would
have laundry shoot up to pick up.
Like it was all day, every day, just
made shit money barely could survive.
And it was all day on,
on call.
If you're watching this live,
don't go to Laurel Canyon right now.
Why is that? If I am, well I am, I go
for as to why I live in Mount Olympus.
My girlfriend has to walk up the fucking
hill and pocked ricotta and the bottom
end of the road, which is like a mile up
the hill, know what's going on. There's a,
there's a cop being shot in a Laurel
Canyon and the guys barricaded himself in
his house. It was domestic uh,
thing and there is a standoff.
I heard about that this morning. That's
still going on. Well she just texts me,
don't drive down this way
because she's woken up the hill.
All right folks, uh, watch
Jim Jeffrey show legit.
It's on Fx FX.
Fx
Two X is we want to explain to them
at a six parody. What happened there?
Why did it go well?
They like comedy,
got a new channel and they
had to move so and so.
I sunny in Philadelphia in the league
or moved over and they've got some back
alley g's on after our show.
That's beautiful. How is it?
I heard the allergy one is a lot of his
old stuff too. That was a, the itch.
It's all this stuff that I had in England
that never had over here with this
whole show, um, with different intros
and stuff like that. Ah, beautiful.
It's really, it's repackaged at
that one, but that's on after me.
Don't worry about that. Worry
about budget. What time is legit?
When should they watch? It's at
10. Unless you have a direct TV,
which means it goes forward to seven
because you get them west coast feed.
But yeah, it's 10 o'clock east
coast. It's 10 o'clock east coast.
Do you enjoy working for Fxx?
Love it. Oh good. Yeah. Yeah.
It's beautiful. Beautiful.
Beautiful. All right. Legit. Watch it.
Um, you don't have a podcast anymore?
Stop doing that. No, I do not have a
podcast at the present moment. I'm on the,
I'm on tour at the moment. If a you
watching them doing a this Saturday,
I will be at a club,
Nokia in La and I'm somewhere
in San Francisco this
Friday. You don't even know.
I think they're both sold out, but
just check anyway. Check your flux.
I tried to go to a website. Mary's
fucking standup comic. Hey, I'm on to,
are there people listening to this in
Australia? Very popular in Australia.
I will be touring the entire month of
April across Australia or major cities for
the whole month.
Glorious, glorious. Ladies and
gentlemen, Jim Jefferies. Thanks brother.
That was a lot of fun. Thanks for
having me. Thanks to our sponsor.
Go to squarespace.com and
use the code word Joe.
That's it, right? Is that what it
is? Squarespace? Yeah. Wait a minute.
Is that it? Yeah. squarespace.com
cohort Joe. Yeah, use a cohort.
Joe.
Save yourself 10% and uh,
thanks also to onnit.com
use the code word Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements
we will hit back. Ladies and gentlemen,
got a lot of podcasts this week.
Much love.